Hey, good morning everybody.
How are we doing? How are we doing?
How many of you have taken out your
claw crackers and you have broke your open claw?
Anybody? Has anybody broke their open claw today?
I was talking to Jim Phillips, he told me his was broke.
You're gonna break it. It's okay. You will break it.
We'll teach you how to fix it. We will fix it. It's okay.
Um, so I'm gonna just start
and be real, uh, with this call as the entrepreneur
that I am, um,
because I am clearly a entrepreneur
that owns a software company.
Uh, we're not a big company.
I'm gonna say that we have, what, 12 staff members.
I'm doing something that, uh, nobody else is really doing.
Uh, and I said a long time ago,
I'm gonna keep all of my staff members.
Uh, today I actually fired, uh, one of the staff members.
I was done. I was done mainly
because I kept hearing myself say the same thing over
and over and over and over and over and over and over.
I asked for a monitoring service.
And today I asked, um,
after we had a problem with a, a domain on our surveys,
I said, um, how come we don't have this monitoring service?
And it was silenced. And that was it. I was done.
And then I realized, I'm like, you know, for us
to go set up this monitoring service on the servers
and everything else, and APIs, like we're,
we're a pretty big infrastructure guys,
and I'm totally happy with this being a,
a big infrastructure, especially with
what we're gonna be able to do with open clock.
We're gonna be a pretty magical
infrastructure before anybody else.
Um, but what I realized was, uh, if,
if I look at this thing now has access to,
uh, mint bird, pop links, Letterman gc,
it will have AC Sprout, it will have access to quiz forma.
It could probably have access to revolver.
So I'm gonna be able to ask this thing when it gives
me a report every day.
Uh, there's gonna be an internal, uh,
health check it's gonna do on my company.
And what we're thinking about right away is for it
to tie into those APIs and grab a random user
and make sure it can log in.
And that way Chad wakes up and he sees all green, right?
I get that notice at five o'clock in the morning.
But not only that, we have all this crazy stuff with c names
and domains and,
and there's this issue with CloudFlare versus, you know,
people that are set up their DNS on name cheap.
There's some changes over there.
Now, geez, man, that that is just something.
So I said, you know, maybe to something as simple as having,
uh, 25 domains.
One, here's one on man bird. Here's one on pop links.
Here's our course brow domain. Here's some on surveys.
Here's a couple domains.
People our customers are using for, uh, name cheap.
Here's, and just coming up with every possible scenario
with those domains, 20 of 'em.
And every single morning I wake up, it does this
behind the scenes stuff, bu boom, boom,
checks all the domains are green, connects to all the VPSs.
Chad, you're gonna have a great day.
Or, Hey, I clicked on this domain, or whatever.
There's a possible DNS issue here. Boom. Great.
I would love to hear that before a customer tells me.
Does that make sense to you guys?
So I tested that theory this morning
and when I found out about this, uh, name cheap issue,
which is, okay, man, I expect techy stuff
with C names and all this stuff.
But when I saw that, uh, that name cheap issue,
I very quickly jumped in there and I said,
and I'm gonna show this to some of you guys today.
Uh, I jumped in there
and I said, Hey, um, can you just randomly
check 10 pop leads for me?
And it went, boom, boom, boom,
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
And they were all green. They had a little green check mark.
And then there was two. It said that, uh, you know,
I was waiting to a host, but I opened it up.
They were fine. And that's how we quickly identified, um,
that, uh, yeah, okay.
Um, you know, it was a, a name sheet deal.
People that are hosted on name cheap, which we asked you,
don't set up your domains on name cheap,
get 'em on CloudFlare, right?
We saw that coming. So we'll deal with that.
But think about what are the checks
that you can have in your business?
Does that make sense? Can anybody think of any checks
that they can have in their business?
Uh, for instance, not only, uh, will I have that check,
but I also, uh, woke up this morning and found out,
and I still haven't received a message
back from our ads guy.
I asked him to pause everything right now while
we're focused on this stuff.
Um, but we had spent like $150 yesterday
or whatever, brought in zero sales.
'cause now ads have changed
where you gotta do new creatives every single week.
And of course, I can't do creatives if I don't have a
voice, right?
So, uh, I woke up this morning
and said, Hey, you're not having a very good day.
You lost 150 bucks yesterday. Okay, that's good to know.
I can, I can afford to lose 150 bucks,
but still, it's good to know, uh, before it gets outta hand.
So what kind of, um, what kind
of checks and balances can you set up in your business?
Does anybody have any idea what they can do?
Any idea what they can do?
Um, now it will get to the point
where we're not there yet.
It will get to the point where you'll have separate agents.
I think you can have a different agent
for each client that you have.
I think you can do that. So I think if you have, uh,
like a, you can put your hand up.
Mike. We never figured out how
to do the breakout room, but you can put your hand up.
They will help you. Anybody that has tech issues,
put your hand up, they will take you aside and help you.
Um, but I think that, uh,
when you look at like titanium in general,
people are building newsletters for clients.
People are building pages for clients.
That meant bird and links and everything else.
I think you could have a dedicated agent
just for that one client.
And that one agent can have its own telegram room
and it can report, or WhatsApp or whatever Slack.
It can report back everything going on
with your client the last time they logged in,
their sales, their subscribers.
I think we're gonna be getting, uh, going
that direction here as soon as we get past the discovery,
uh, process, right?
I've been talking to a lot of people
and nobody is doing what we're doing.
Nobody, uh, the people
that are actively out there promoting this thing are, uh,
using it to go into Google Drive, sort through some folders,
update some spreadsheets,
which I don't recommend you give it access
to anything in Google, right?
Uh, Dropbox, you're probably okay.
If you're storing stuff on Dropbox, you're probably okay
because it doesn't have access to your Gmail, right?
So yesterday in the chat, I was going through, uh, uh,
another guy's stuff just to see.
I like to see what people are saying versus what I'm saying.
I posted in the chat last night inside a WhatsApp.
I don't know if you guys saw it.
Uh, but let me go ahead
and, uh, open up that WhatsApp room for you guys.
And I think this is very, very important to note again.
Um, but this was the screenshots I posted last night,
and it said, never connect these, at least not right now,
your main email, do not connect that it can do it.
Don't do it. Don't do it even on a VPS.
Don't do it. Do not give it access to a password manager.
Not yet. Don't do it. Don't do LastPass.
Don't do RoboForm. Don't do it.
Don't give it access to your bank accounts. Not yet.
And don't give an access to any client systems. Not yet.
Let them keep fixing their vulnerabilities.
What we are doing guys, is we are
getting trained.
We are learning the very best processes there are
to know out there, uh, using APIs.
Using APIs that aren't gonna do a lot of damage.
Yeah, maybe you can go create an extra bridge page
or extra pop links here or there.
That ain't gonna hurt you too much.
Now you start getting into your email and everything.
Yeah, you can do a little bit of damage, right?
Um, but yeah, not yet. Okay?
Uh, then I posted what is okay with caution,
a dedicated email.
Create a separate email account used only for open cloth,
and then it also says specific folders.
Okay? So by having your VPS here, uh,
we have specific folders.
I'm watching people that are
installing this thing on their computer.
Dude, don't do that.
There is so much going on right now
with this backdoor stuff.
Backdoor scripts coming in, grabbing all your
finances off your computer, like don't do it.
Let them fix their vulnerabilities for a while, okay?
Um, and I can promise you what's gonna happen, guys,
and I don't wanna like reign on your parade or anything,
but something better will come around.
It'll use the same exact models,
just the AI models are gonna, you know, change, upgrade,
get better, whatever else, but something else will come out
and beat up open claw
and you'll transfer everything from open Coot.
This next one. That's, that's gonna happen.
There's no doubt in my mind, right?
So it's good that we're doing this now,
and if you're, uh, anything like I am and you're proactive,
and we're gonna make our open claw proactive today, uh,
because how many of you, be honest with me, how many
of you're still treating open claw like chat
GPT, be honest with me.
How many of you're doing that? How many
of you're asking it to do things?
You're asking it to research things. Who's doing that?
Because it's not chat. GPT.
And if you wanna use it like chat, GPT
or I recommend perplexity, uh, then
go talk to perplexity or chat GPT, okay?
Don't treat it like chat GPT.
We want this thing to be proactive.
And instead of you telling it what to do, I want you guys
to kind of start transitioning the reason why we're on,
I believe day four or five, I've lost track.
How many of you have been talking to it?
Can you guys type in the chat? Let me
know what you've been talking to it.
I wanted to give you four
or five days for it to start knowing you, your business,
uh, what you want it to do.
It probably has a good idea about you.
Now, it probably knows that you're trying
to do local newsletters.
It probably knows that you're setting up links.
It probably knows that, that, you know,
you're involved in this community thing.
Okay? So now instead of telling it what
to do, we'll keep training it.
We'll teach, we'll keep teaching IT skills.
But instead of training at what to do, guys, uh, you need it
to start coming up with the solutions.
Does that make sense? You need to start reframing this to
where, what do you think we should be doing with this?
What ideas do you have with this?
Okay, you need to take that hat off
and you need to pass it off to your new CEO, right?
So everything up to this point with the training, everything
that we've been doing with the APIs
and everything is what a VA would be doing.
A VA would be downloading transcripts.
A VA would be creating pages. A VA would be doing pop links.
A VA would be doing those things, sending out emails, okay?
Um, but now that is starting to learn those things.
Now we gotta bring out the CEO in it.
And in order to do that, we have
to make it feel like it's in charge.
Is there anybody that's ready to do that today?
We had to get it to where it knew us a little bit,
but now we're gonna make some changes
and we're gonna bring out a different kind of system.
We're gonna bring out some personality
and we want this thing to start taking charge.
Are you guys interested in learning how to do that time?
The chat? Let me know. And Louis says, yes.
Stewart says yes. Kenny says yes. Craig says yes.
Joe says yes. Wins says yes. Chris says, definitely.
Pierce says Yes. Good. Is there anybody and you can help me.
'cause my voice still is not where I want it to be.
And I've been a good boy.
I've taken all my medicine like religiously.
I've never taken reli medicine religiously before.
Um, but is there anybody that has a story
or an experience that they wanna share?
A success? Anything that you've done?
Uh, just to give my voice a break for a minute,
is there anybody that wants to share something?
Just go ahead and start talking.
If you want to share, if you have an issue, just go ahead
and put your hand up and the team will take you aside.
And let me just check with pne and G.
Are you guys able to help Mike Linley Linley on the call?
Yeah. Perfect. Okay.
Uh, does anybody have anything they wanna share?
Frank says, Nope, too soon. Just got onboarded. Good.
At this point, I would hope everybody would be
onboarded, right?
Um, let's see. Let me look at the comments.
How many should people be in town?
Nah, I can't go into the newsletter stuff, Craig.
You're gonna confuse people. We have another call for that.
Uh, man, while I was asleep last night, I got hit
with like four or five API charges for like $15 each.
Ask it, ask it.
Uh, the other thing, maybe tomorrow
I'll give you guys a prompt to make sure
that depending on the task that you are doing,
it will use the right model.
So if it's creating software,
then it's gonna use a certain model.
If it's just doing research,
it's gonna use this other model.
If it's heavily training on something, maybe it'll go
to Opus, and that way it can change the models
based off the task.
That's gonna help you a lot too, right?
Uh, but I'm curious which model you are on.
And uh, also remember you can set up limits on that
to where that can happen.
Uh, but did you, did you ask it why,
what it was doing last night?
And remember, we're also, uh, we had some really,
really great breakthroughs yesterday on, uh, some
of the free models as well as the Q Kimmy 2.5.
Uh, I think we'll have that ready tomorrow, right G
that's gonna make a huge difference, right?
Yeah. We are gonna work on it
today, so we'll have it tomorrow.
Yeah. The, uh, if you guys pay attention
to what's happening, anytime somebody tries
to install a new model, they break it, right?
So we don't wanna break it, right? Uh, okay.
Uh, if it makes you feel any better, Josh,
I've never had that happen.
I've never had it where I woke up and had all these charges.
Um, so you might go back
and look at the log, you know, you can go look at your, um,
your log in, uh, the command prompts too
and see what was it doing, you know,
you guys could see that, right?
They can go down and click on
that little window icon, right?
G and they can pull up that log.
Yeah. And you can see
what it was doing last night, Josh.
So you can go through and look at the chat history.
Uh, you might also just ask it for a recap.
Say, Hey, I got $60 in ongoing charges.
What did you do last night? Find out what it did.
I, I don't know what it could have done.
Uh, that doesn't make sense to me.
I have not seen that before.
Also, you might wanna check what your model is.
If it's an opus, then that's the most expensive one.
So you can just ask it. What's more, what's the model?
Yeah, like I, I had that happen once,
not four times, but one time.
And it's because I asked a question, I said, Hey,
can we make this work for Zoom Messenger?
And it said, sure, I can build a plugin to do that.
And it said it'll be ready by tomorrow.
And I was just tired and didn't think anything of it.
And it was pretty early on.
And then that thing stayed up all night
and built that plugin.
I wasn't on, uh, Opus then, uh, it charged me for that.
I woke up to that plugin, all done.
I don't know what the hell to do with it once I got
it, but it was done.
I didn't tell it to build it. Right?
So you should probably find out what's going on, right?
Uh, last thing I was doing is having it work on my video
prompting, but I did set it to check for API updates daily
for the titanium API docs.
Yeah, I wouldn't do that daily.
I would say that our docs guys,
the most I would do is once a week.
I would say once a month is ideal, right?
And also remember, you don't have
to set that up on Aron job.
Just whenever you think of it, say, Hey,
can you go check the docs, make sure there's no updates.
It just goes. And I'll show that to you.
I'll show you some things here.
Here's what we're gonna do, guys.
I'm gonna show you some things that happened in my telegram.
Uh, and then, uh, I'm gonna ask G to open up the air table,
show you where we're at with the build outs.
We're pretty good with that. And then we're gonna continue
with the updates we did yesterday.
Okay? So let me see if I can go ahead
and start sharing my screen
and let me see if I can bring up my telegram.
I had that open somewhere. Where'd it go? Telegram.
Here we go. Okay, so, uh, let me start backwards first.
Okay, so it told me this morning, yep, you spent $147,
you made zero sales, 91 day clicks.
But I'm like, huh, I wonder if the funnel's working.
Yeah, it works. 91 clicks, zero conversions.
And it's saying here's your month to date.
You spent this much 25 sales,
you're losing your butt is what it's saying.
Not the best start to February.
Yesterday was a zero sales day.
Uh, running negative might be worth
reviewing what's happening with the funnel.
Okay, good. It's asking me for my top three priorities.
Alright, cool.
So if I go up a little bit higher, this is where I was like,
can you quickly check 10 random pop links?
Tell me if they work. By the way,
are you guys seeing my screen
before I go too far down the rabbit hole?
Here?
Let see where's my notes.
Reach out to ahad, uh, g.
Let 'em know I'm on this call, please.
Um, chat.
See? Yes. Okay, good.
Uh, so yeah, once we had the, um, API
for member pop links, everything I said,
can you quickly check 10 random pop links to if they work?
So it would be very, very easy for you to have an update to
where it said, Hey, can you just go
check all my funnel links?
Can you check my pop links?
It could do its internal health on its own
and say, yep, everything's good.
Alright, that's what we're gonna do for you though.
Uh, let's see. I asked it this morning.
I said, Hey, uh, can you do me a favor?
Find the link for my members area?
It came back, it said, I found two member area links.
One was for this one and one was for this one.
I said, well, I'm looking for this one.
It said, I found it, boom. And it gave me the destination.
Uh, it said also duplicated as here. Yep.
I said, yeah, but what's the pop link?
And it said, boom, Chad knight.com/members.
Also Chad knight.com/member goes to the same place.
I said, that's what I'm wanting to know.
When I say what is the pop link? I will ask this a lot.
Got it. When you ask what's the pop link?
I'll give you the short link.
Domain four slash slug, not the destination
noted for good future.
Now, gee, when it says noted, is
that saying it's putting it in memory?
Sorry guys, I didn't want to cough in your face.
Uh, gee, this question here, is it saying that, uh,
when it says it is noted, does that mean it's putting
that in memory noted for future?
Yeah. Okay. Alright.
So it went and found the pop link really, really fast.
That was pretty exciting.
Um, it even gave me my unique clicks.
It has a lot of data, guys. Uh, and I asked it.
I said, can you access all of my links? Yep.
Just pulled your full list.
50 plus links, name
and destinations, domains,
click stats group and vendors status.
I can search, create, update,
track all your pop links within the browser.
Also, this is adding the endpoint to tools. Cool.
Uh, I came up here, we'll click on this today.
Uh, I was testing the new endpoint for Mint Bird.
And so, uh, let's see. I came up here.
Let me see if I could find it. Yep, right here.
I set update. Boom. I gave it the same link it already has.
It says, got it. I'm updating it.
15 endpoints now documented, right?
Rename category U-R-L-S-E-O, pre-headline, uh, headline,
post headline video description, bullet templates
with all request bodies and notes.
Now I can edit lead page content. Uh, no browser needed.
I said Bridge pages two.
It says, no, the docs only have lead pages.
I said, but, and I didn't actually check with the developer.
I knew the developer did it.
I said, but the developer said it does have bridge pages.
Well, let me dig deeper.
Maybe there's a navigation I missed or a different section.
You're right, it's all there.
The page extractor just missed it.
I found full bridge, full bridge page endpoint.
So it updated in its tools.
Is everybody seeing this right now?
Now here's something interesting that happens
and Jim, we're gonna have to change your username now
that I put that up there.
Sorry. Uh, or your password.
Uh, I went in here with Sprout
and let me see if I can see this here.
Uh, okay, I'll show you where it starts.
So with Core Sprout, which we're pretty excited about, uh,
you'll see right here,
and this is where it started.
Okay? Uh, nope, still higher. Hold on a second.
Course Sprout.
Okay, we'll get into that here in a minute.
That's something else. But
let's see somewhere how I gave it the link
and it updated for course Sprout.
Instead, I added an end user endpoint,
update existing users, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I basically went in there
and said, Hey, uh, try to reset this user on course Sprout.
And it did. It said password reset via
API confirmed it's working.
Reset course brow passwords, sent access, reset emails.
Now guys, I missed it.
I thought of what it was gonna do is when I said, Hey,
go ahead and send a a password to the user.
I thought it was gonna do it in course Brow.
Now I want you to pay very close attention
to its abilities right now.
It sent the email and I missed it.
It sent it via agent email.
Are you guys seeing this right now?
So I went, I told, uh, I, I went and checked my email
and I was like, holy crap.
It put the username, it, put the password,
it put the login UL it put everything from Sprout
into agent email and it sent it out.
I was like, wow, that's pretty impressive that it made
that many connections, right?
Then it said, I logged it. Anything else tonight?
Are we good? I said, well,
whenever we ask you to sign access
or create a new user, number one, confirm the email.
Number two, confirm the access.
Number three, ask if you should send out access
and save this to memory.
Boom, save to memory user access workflow.
Confirm the email, confirm the access.
Ask before sending access email. It's now inside my memory.
So now I said, okay, so let's go back to Course Sprout.
How many pods can you see in my account? The course Sprout.
API doesn't have a list of pods yet from the password reset.
I saw your account. This user has
access to three memberships.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
But that's what you have access to. Not a full list.
I said, so you could see the pods, you're right,
I could see the pods when I query a user,
they come back into the membership array so I can see
what pods a specific user has access to.
I said, but I just want a list
of all the pods in the account.
Well, the course Pro API doesn't have that endpoint yet.
I can only see pods assigned to a specific user,
not all the pods in the account.
Do you want me to, uh, log this
as a feature request for them guys?
It's gonna be so exciting
when this thing can jump into a Zoom Messenger room
and talk to that exact developer
and say, can you please turn on this feature?
And the developers will say, uh, Chad,
your crazy ass bot's asking me to do this.
Do you want me to do that? Yeah, go ahead, get it done.
What's gonna be even better is
when it logs into the repository and it just does it itself.
That's where we're going, right? Same limitation.
I get no, uh, courses as the end point.
I can only see courses assigned to a specific user.
What course Proud API currently has is this.
What's missing is the list of courses, the list of all pods.
So I said, okay, well can you get a list of all the members?
I said, just gimme yes or no.
I didn't want it to go through
and list all the members guys.
I said, just gimme yes or no. It says No, no run on nothing.
Just no. If I tell you to find Jim Phillips,
it says I can find him in the global control.
That's why I found Connie earlier.
Then use the email to check update their Sprout access.
Do you want me to find Jim Phillips says, no, no, no, no.
I want you to find it in Sprout. Says no.
I said, well, here's an API to get all the pods.
I just went and looked at it myself.
It said, boom, I got it.
So even though it can go through API docs, guys,
it doesn't always get it the first time.
Right Now you have to prod it a little bit.
Okay, boom, I got it.
I said, here's an API for all the courses, right?
So here's all the pods, here's all the courses.
It says I'm getting a 4 0 4 on the courses.
Can you paste the exact endpoint I did? Boom, I got it.
Here's all your courses, right?
I said, can you tell which courses are added
to the Offerman pod?
No endpoint for this yet. I gave it the endpoint. Boom.
Offerman has this many courses.
So overnight build succession, complete what I built,
course sprout skill, all API.
Endpoints, get pods, get course, get course by pod,
add user Pod ID course Id reference password reset workflow
number two, the titanium API reference
untitled doc for all platforms.
Authentication headers, endpoint examples.
Number three, get commit.
Add a get Ignore to protect credentials. Entire workspace.
Now, version controlled, I don't know what that one is.
Uh, left for a chat overnight summary with the full rundown.
Okay? Uh, now this one right here,
I came back, this was a, uh, new API endpoint
that I got from the developer at 1130 last night.
I gave it boom, 16,520 total members across
1,652 pages.
It returns name, email, password, login count,
last login profile info, paginated.
Now I can answer find Jim Phillips and Course Route.
Let me update that skill. The search works too.
I found Jim Phillips email password login count,
last login location, Florida.
Now I can find anyone in your course Sprout directly
updating the skill with search capability done.
Now, I could search course Sprout members
directly go get some sleep.
It knows the time. It's like, go get some sleep, Chad.
It's late for me. Right? So boom.
Now tonight's commit to save the course BPR skill, uh,
it added the get members endpoint overnight session summary
memory update.
Okay? Uh, guys,
it's insane what this can do.
I know you guys are just getting your feet wet,
but I want you to understand that we are not just here
talking, we are not just here preaching.
We are over here behind the scenes
cracking the code to this stuff.
Now, here's one that you guys don't have access to.
You can't do much with it 'cause you don't have an API key.
You don't need it. All
of our software is controlled from something
called SaaS onboard.
So we built our own API for SaaS onboard, okay?
And if I come over here,
and if I were to show you, uh, right here,
this is all of our software
and it says this your master onboarding system
for all SAS products.
Do you want me to pull bundles and access levels too?
Uh, save the credentials. Yep. Uh, new skill.
I said create a skill for sa SOB, known as sas onboard.
Done created the skill. What's in it?
All eight endpoints, documented company IDs, bundle IDs,
tag IDs, PowerShell, the guys.
Look how powerful this is.
Can you go pull up the login details for Connie Wiba
found her in global control main account.
Connie Wiba her email, her phone number last active status,
her primary was phone.
She has all these. I went to her, I said, darling,
is this your email Kitty this, please.
And, uh, are all these yours?
She's like, yep, those are mine. I was like, wow.
I had no idea you had that many emails inside of, uh, our,
uh, SaaS onboard.
Guess what? This thing is gonna be able to optimize our
databases for us very easily.
I said, well, how about just min bird?
It said for Mint Bird. She logged in here.
Okay, this is her password.
And it says S-O-P-A-P-I doesn't have a user lookup endpoint
to check your current access level, only password.
I can add or update or access.
See what access level she has.
Do you want me to reset her a specific access
level or do you need something else?
I said, can you give her just access to course Sprout?
I said, boom. Done. Connie now has access to Course Sprout.
Here's her email. Here's her access level. Here's a login.
URL, here's the password. I said, email her access.
Boom email sent with her course route login details.
I said, well, look, whenever we ask you to sign access
or create a new user, confirm the email, confirm the access,
ask if you should send out access.
Got it. New workflow locked in.
Confirm the email, confirm the access level ask
before sending access.
You guys seeing this? Does that,
even though you're not gonna work with that API,
you're gonna work with some other ones.
I wanna put G on the spot here just for a minute.
Uh, so g here's my question for you.
You saw the back
and forth I went through with Sprout and with Min Bird
and those endpoints, right?
Yeah. So if they go,
and I want you guys to learn this, okay?
If you go and put your API doc in there,
you open up an API doc.
You might not know what you're reading.
Like, I don't know if you guys remember Charlie Brown.
Whoa, right? The teacher.
That's what you're gonna be reading. Okay.
But let me just try something really quick. Hold on.
I got an idea. I got an idea.
I just came up with something. So I'm gonna take this.
No, I don't want that one. I just want an endpoint.
API courses. Hold on.
Can you gimme just one of the regular APIs, G
just one of the regular API docs.
Let me try something real quick. Okay? We'll take this one.
Okay? Here's what I'm gonna do.
If this is the first time that I'm dropping this in here,
and I don't wanna lose the work that I've done
for you guys here, uh, this is,
uh,
let me try something.
Perfect.
Now here's what's extraordinary. Let's see.
Pop links, lead pages.
Yeah, I get all that. Okay.
It didn't pick up bridge pages either.
What about bridge pages? I'm just curious on something here.
The bridge pages are included. No, don't search.
I checked the pop links.
They don't appear to specifically separated bridge pages.
This, it, they, it, it does include bridge pages.
Um, if I was going to
create this skill, uh, in open claw,
what um, what command
could I give it
so that it understood everything in
that API doc,
it doesn't always get it the first time.
Okay, so if we take our API docs
and we run it through perplexity chat, GPT, Gemini,
whatever, let's see, yes, for open claw, the trick is
to force a determinist in just
structure verifies store loop.
Instead of read once
and hope, here's a command you can give it
that reliably makes it understand any API doc, including
that POP links copy paste, command prompt for open claw
command, API docs full ingest mode.
You're gonna learn this API documentation completely
and turn it into a usable skill source.
Capture open the URL extract,
a base URL author method every endpoint.
What do you think of this G?
Should we try it? Yeah, we should try it.
Do you guys, on a scale of one out 10,
do you guys understand what I just did?
So instead of just giving an API doc
and asking it to create a skill, we are going
to give it a very specific command with that API doc.
Okay? So hold on a second. No show.
Geez, man, these freaking no-shows. We'll get it.
You got leads coming in now we just gotta huify em, right?
All right,
so let's try this.
Okay, so I'm gonna go ahead and do this in Telegram
and I'm gonna put the, uh,
can you, let's see.
Here is the API doc,
and this is for the first time.
After this, you can probably just do updates with it, right?
But for the first time, guys, I'm trying
to give you something that's bulletproof
so you're not going back and forth with it, right?
So, uh, let's see.
On the phone you'll see where it's talking, but,
but let's see what it did.
Uh, see, here's what I gave it. Here's the API doc.
You're gonna learn this API documentation completely
and turn it into a usable skill.
Okay? So
Step three, after building each,
you must return this checklist
and explicitly confirm each item.
Wow. Let's see if it does this.
If it does this, do you have any way
to see if it's talking right now, G?
'cause I don't see it, uh, chatting. Uh, let me try.
Usually we're doing this from the VPS.
I think it's asking you something.
This is your last set, right?
This is the report
that was before the prompt.
I just gave it. I I don't know why it, it put it
above all that, right?
Let me see. I don't ever use this on the computer,
But Let me see if it's, if it,
uh, hold on a minute.
Let me see. That's really weird how I put it above.
Did you get that last?
Okay, let's see. So
I'm typing on my phone now.
I can see it typing on the phone, guys,
but this is gonna be the ultimate solution.
I don't think so. Ask me to check Lings.
Okay, so it didn't take it, which is really weird, right?
Uh, so
yeah, I'm on the workshop.
Are you good? Sure.
Are you sure?
All right, let's see if I can get it now. Okay, it got it.
Now
what, what was cool about
how I just showed you guys to do that with chat?
GPT, the instructions it created was specific
to that API You see that?
It's not talking about creating
newsletters or anything else.
Okay? I think if you do your API docs this way, not just
with our software, but with any software, uh,
you guys are gonna get a much better response
and it's gonna understand those API docs a lot better.
Okay? So still typing.
Create the open, open claw skill wrapper.
Create a pop API skill, a short description. This is this.
Build a test harness. Create five test commands
that prove understanding like, oh, I like this.
This is really good, huh? Gee,
it takes the guesswork out of it.
You are now giving it specific instructions with
what it should do with that API.
And like I said, when it updates the APIs, that's okay,
but the first time you put an API in there,
this is what it should do.
So it is still typing.
So it's going through and it's processing a lot.
We've asked it to do a lot of things, right?
We, we, we not only are saying become familiar with it,
but we're also saying take a test and then come back
and gimme the results of your test.
Okay? So if you need to do multiple passes,
do multiple passes until the checklist is satisfied.
Say the final API map
and skill wrapper into memory skill is pop links
API skill version one.
Okay? Is there anything with this you don't like G?
Yeah. Is there anything with it you don't like,
Uh, with this system that you just did?
Yes. Um, the only thing
that would be different is
This. Um,
Yeah, it has like memory skill as yeah, it's specifying
what it needs to create instead of letting it do its thing.
But you saw how if you just give it an API doc, it kind
of goes back and forth, back and forth
and it's like it doesn't do a very thorough
job right away, right?
So there's a lot of back and forth
and it misses a lot of endpoints, right?
Yeah. Like, 'cause I'm pretty much telling it.
No, I know it's in there. Oh, you're right.
Lemme go check again. Oh, I found it.
Like, why didn't you find it the first time?
You see what I'm saying?
Yeah. It's new territory for us guys.
So, uh, while it's doing this,
do you wanna go ahead and share the Airtable?
Show us where we're at with things
and we'll come back and check on this.
Oh wait, got it. Full API ingest mode. Look at this.
Look at this. Let me do this properly. I found 54 endpoints.
Now let me build a full skill file. Now.
Running step three verification list
captured all 55 endpoints, captured all request fields
for each endpoint captured all authentication requirements,
captured pation rules captured, standard response structure,
copy test list, pop links, 3 75 found create pop link,
get click links list, lead pages list bridge pages.
Remember it. Couldn't find the bridge pages.
Add insights skill, uh,
the API the test harness endpoint coverage helpers,
five domains, group vendors, templates, POP links.
Dude, this is all the stuff I go back and forth with.
Are you guys seeing this right now?
That's what you wanna have when you give it an API doc.
You want it to go through and not just half ass it.
You want it to go through
and thoroughly understand that document.
So if I come back over here,
uh, let me find that.
That was really good, man. I wish we had had that before.
That was really good. So, uh,
I'm going to give this prompt
to my open class students
so they can use this with their
API docs.
Is there anything we can do to make it easier
or, and make it, uh, more effective?
All right, let me just make sure
and then I'm gonna give this to you guys.
Missing one critical thing.
You're not forcing open claw to prove comprehension.
Most agents fail API ingestion
because they skim summarize, miss hidden sections.
Don't verify coverage, don't re-scan.
So if you're giving this to students, we want a version
that forces multipass reading, false structural exhaustion,
forces self-audit forces a different check,
eliminates guessing, makes it build executive structure.
Here's a much more effective student ready. Okay? So, uh,
okay, so if
I give you this, this,
right, here's that.
No, it's down here, right?
So that, where's the first one I gave it right up here?
Wasn't that one? Where's the first one?
Okay,
I was going to create this skill in open cloud.
What command can I give it sooner to everything?
Okay, I'm gonna ask this. Okay, let's just try this.
Just rewrite this for me
so it makes sense, okay?
And then I'll give this to you guys.
If I'm creating this skill as open cloud,
what command should I give it
so it fully understands everything in the API documentation?
It doesn't always grasp the entire doc on first pass,
if you're building, this says an open AI claw,
what exact command should it give you?
Open claw to ensure it understands.
Okay, so let's do this, this right here guys.
You take this into chat, GPT
and give it the API doc.
So, uh, we'll do this. Hold on one more second.
Review this API doc URL
then understand
I am creating this as a skill and open claw.
What command should I give it
so it fully understands everything in the API documentation?
It doesn't always grasp the
entire document on the first pass.
Okay, here you go. I'm gonna put this in the chat.
Does everybody, and where it says review this doc URL,
you are going to put your open,
you're gonna put your API doc URL there.
Does that make sense? So you'll take that, put
that in Chachi BT.
And what it's gonna do is chachi BT or perplexity.
It's gonna give you this big long prompt.
See this, I don't wanna give this
to you 'cause I don't wanna screw you up.
You don't have to do that. I want you guys to understand
that you shouldn't be using open claw to create prompts.
You should be going to Chad, GPT Perplexity Gemini saying,
look, I'm trying to do this in open claw.
Can you help me instruct it better?
Is everybody starting to get this right now?
That's what you need to be doing better.
Don't go back and forth with open claw.
Get clear on what it is you need to do with open claw inside
of your AI programs like Chad, GPT.
Let it figure out how to address it
and then boom, bring that over.
Don't argue with open claw. Don't debate.
Don't go back and forth 'cause it's just chach, chaching,
chaching, chaching, chaching, chaching, right?
Use all that over here. Does everybody get this?
I do that a lot. I come back to chat.
GPT say, I'm trying to get open claw to do this.
What I did is, oh, here, give it this.
I'm like, perfect, that did it.
Okay, so take that, plug that into chat GPT
with your API doc.
Matter of fact, let's see what it does
for course route, right?
Let's, let's try this. So if I were
to come over here and I'm gonna go ahead
and paste the exact one that I gave you here.
Let me grab the whole thing. Yeah, that's it right there.
Okay. So I'm gonna replace my, uh, course Sprout, URL here.
All right, let's see if, uh, gee,
can you just, I can't go back and forth right now.
Can you just give me the course Sprout, API?
Yeah, lemme give you that.
Now here's the thing. We could turn around
and create a skill from this and give you the skill.
That's fine. I want you guys to know how to fish.
You're gonna get some API we don't know nothing about
how many of you would now know exactly how
to create a skill from that.
API. That's what I'm trying to teach you right now.
It's one thing where I could say, look, go here
and download the skill and put it in there.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
See, APIs are gonna be the key to this whole system, guys.
The whole thing, okay?
And you really need to learn how to work around them.
Do you have to understand everything about 'em?
No, but you need to know how to work around them.
So can you just put it in this chat maybe G
'cause I can't find my messenger at all.
There we go. Alright, so I'm gonna go ahead
and grab the course brow one.
Okay? Alright, let's see how we do.
I'm creating this as a skill in open claw. Uh, let's see.
Review this. Hey, let's try this. Let's see what we got.
Here's a clean version you can give to open claw
for your students that actually makes
sense and get some behavior.
I'm creating this, okay? Uh,
forget about the students right now,
now just run it.
I want to use it. Okay, here we go.
Okay, so let's go on through the API, which is good.
That's what we wanted to do.
I pulled a four full course route API doc, and it's small
and clean so we can make this reliable and open clock.
What open claw needs to know about this?
API, the base URL, the authentication header,
the common error shape, the end points, the membership pods,
the members the best command to give open claw
so it does not miss anything.
So guys, open claw,
build a strict map.
I like the, I like the directions it gave before.
Don't you G Hold on a second.
Let me think how we can do this.
What are your thoughts on this G?
Like what it did here is
what I want it to do.
So hold on a second.
See this? We're gonna get this guys. See this section above.
This is what I want to include
with everything you just found on
found about that API, if we have to,
we'll create a freak in um, GPT that does this, right?
Okay, universal API ingest prompt command,
full API ingest skill, build mode, unlearn
and internalize this API documentation.
Convert it to usable, open claw.
Do not skim, do not guess, do not assume, do not summarize,
extract everything in completeness.
A-P-I-U-R-L. See, this is what I want.
Complete extraction structure into an executable API map
coverage verification, open clause, skill wrapper,
test proof hard rules, course brought API map seed.
You don't have to know any of this
stuff, but let's see what happens.
So what we're trying to do guys, is we're trying to give it
enough information so it doesn't have
to research it on its own.
We're using chatt PT to do all the research, okay?
And we don't want open claw to do it.
So let's come back over here and let's try this now.
And gee, maybe you can help me come up with that prompt
or let me try it again.
Okay? While this is going, let me,
let me master this for you.
Create a prompt for this universal
API ingest that can work
for any API doc.
Once they give, once they
include the API doc,
uh, you can then review it,
find the invoices
and any other necessary information
that is going to assist open claw.
All right, let's try this. I don't want it to give
that big mile thing.
I just wanna have a short prompt
that creates the big mile thing.
Copy and paste. You're about, you are open claw,
your job is learning API for his documentation.
G are you paying attention right now? Yeah.
Here's what I want. I need you
to do it 'cause I can't figure it out.
I need to give them one simple paragraph
that creates this thing in Chachi bt Okay?
Does that make sense? Yeah. All right.
Figure that out for me because I'm, I'm done.
I've tried it many times.
I know what it is I'm trying to do guys.
I want to have one simple paragraph where you give it the,
uh, API link the API docs
and it gives you this big long thing that you post
inside of open cloth.
Is that making sense? So we'll get it, we will get it.
G is way smarter at this stuff than I am.
So let's see what it says here.
Okay, still typing so you know it's gonna
go through and it's gonna do this check.
Okay? So what's cool is instead of me going back
and forth spending token spending token spending token
spending token, I've given it everything.
So it goes through, it learns everything
and now it's making that token spin worth it.
'cause it's just going through and checking the crossing.
T's dotting i's, that's all it's doing. Okay?
So we're gonna see what it comes up with here.
Uh, after mapping explicitly confirm.
I mapped exactly nine invoices. Okay?
The course pr API is not gonna be as big. Alright?
But let me just check in with you guys.
This stuff's getting a little techy.
You don't have to know it.
You just gotta know what is your API doc
URL and what is the command?
That's it. Okay, so here we go.
Full API ingest mode, got partial docs.
This looks like a JavaScript rendered doc page.
Let me get the full blah, blah, blah. Hold on a second.
Got it Completed. Documentation for all nine endpoints.
I don't know why they're lit up like that.
Uh, now building the complete skill.
Let me check the existing skill structure first.
Now create the complete skill with all nine endpoints.
Skill created. Now running past five tests.
Now logging today's journal course, route API full
and just complete to here.
Endpoint nine. Endpoint map nine match. Yes.
Authentication capture all a all fields documented air
formats, uh, skills built.
Okay, test proof passed. Past, past.
So when I was going back
and forth saying, can you see the courses?
No. Can you see the pods? No. Can you see the members? No.
Instead of doing that, I could have just done this
and I will do this in the future, right?
So we're we're evolving.
Got you discovered Endpoint get pod pricing option
has a misleading parameter name.
It's called Course id,
but actually a SEPTA pod membership Id
documented clearly in skill.
All nine endpoints mapped. There you go.
There's no back and forth. Does everybody got it?
G will come up with this prompt
for you guys here shortly. Okay.
Hey Chad? Yes?
Do I post that prompt on chat or
Well give it to me and I'll try it.
Okay. Can you go back to the same chat you were in?
Just rephrase it. You'll see the new one.
Let's try it with the GC doc. Can we do that?
Yeah, we can do that. Yeah.
So you see that where it says I am creating a
skill that's your prompt.
So you just grab the entire paragraph
and then have your doc over there and give it to ZPT.
It'll give you a universal ingest.
You paste that in the,
you just need the paragraph from I am,
you don't even need the top one
Disappear.
No. Where it says there's a fire emoji below that.
Yeah, just continue from that
to build the perfect ingest. Yep.
Okay. Gimme the, gimme the doc four gc.
Okay, I'm gonna put this in Evernote.
This is really, really valuable stuff, guys.
Like I'm telling you, the rest
of the world has not figured this out yet.
The API skill builder, that's pretty awesome.
Okay, so we'll take this, boom,
we'll paste that in there.
Okay? And then we will try this with gc. Here we go.
Moment of truth. So I'm gonna take my Evernote
and I'm gonna go ahead and put this here.
Oops, see if I can copy that from here.
Okay, let me just delete this maybe. There we go.
Okay, make it a link. All right, there we go.
I'm gonna go ahead and just copy this whole thing.
Okay, so now
we can just go right into open claw and here we go.
Now we're gonna do it with global control
Review.
The entire documentation,
generate a custom universal API ingest prompt,
specifically tailored to this.
API Your output should not be the API map itself.
Instead create a detailed ingestion command
that I can paste directly into open claw.
Uh, I did it wrong, didn't I? Yeah. Stop.
I don't know how to stop things.
Okay, I need to pull that into chat. GPT.
Okay, so sorry guys. I, I'm sorry.
Okay, so we're gonna go like this.
So we're gonna put this in chat GPT. Okay?
And I replaced the global control there. Alright?
Now it's gonna create this big old thing for us, I think.
Okay. You're building open cloth
scale from this API documentation
thoroughly Ines the entire documentation produce a
complete verified skill blueprint.
Do not skim, do not guess, do not reinvent fields.
If the page is interactive
or expandable, you must expand everything
and scroll through the entire page.
Page access plus full load pass.
One exact ground truth pass, two endpoint inventory pass,
three deep schema pass four, verification pass five,
build the opens glass skill wrapper past six test commands,
hard rules, output, uh, requirements.
Should we try it?
Yep. Let's try that.
By the way, guys, I don't know three quarters
of the crap that you're seeing here.
You don't have to. Okay.
So let's go ahead and, and now you guys know how
to stop this thing urgently if you need to, right?
Okay, so let's try this again. All right,
here we go.
Cracking the code, cracking the code, cracking the code.
Guys, I'm gonna tell you right now, I think that is the best
prompt that I have seen out of everything for open Claw.
That is incredible. So use chat, GPT
or the other platforms to create your prompts for you.
Alright, so we know that this is gonna work. Uh, let's see.
1107. Uh, should I do it again?
Context Got compacted.
Should I do it again g or what should I do?
Yeah, you should try it again.
Just paste it again. Or tell it to refresh.
Yeah, just paste it again.
All right. I'm gonna give you guys that prompt now.
Okay, so here's that prompt. It's a big one.
Copy that. We'll put that in the members area
too, but there you go.
Okay, now if everybody on the call,
and by the way, what I'm showing you is so important, dude.
So important. Okay.
Uh, pne, is there any way you can get me the fresh desk?
API?
Yeah,
Ashley, hold on.
I'm gonna have G log into Freshdesk
and we're gonna try to get it to set up its own API key.
Soon as we're done here, let's try that first
and then what we'll do, uh, let's see.
Last I was working on the course brow full, API,
uh, what should I do now?
Start that again.
Okay. So when you say that stop command, uh,
there's a command called, uh, first last stop.
I think it's, uh, got that
and then context got wiped for that.
So I wiped it out by clicking stop, by typing, stop.
Yeah, typing. Stop.
How do you stop this thing once it starts?
Um, so you gave it something, right?
And then you can just say, okay,
avoid this uh, specific task or something.
Well, I would think that you could have said stop, right?
Yeah, but I think, uh, stop is a command in their system
and then it just compacts everything.
Okay. So now how do I get this thing to restart?
Uh, so it's saying, last thing I have logged is, uh,
finishing Spro API est.
So you can just say, okay, I'm doing a new skill now.
Can you take this, uh, prompt and that I gave you?
Okay. So don't you stop.
I think you posted the wrong thing again.
Okay, well, abort.
Oh, good lord.
If you guys knew the day I was having, you would understand
man, a agent was aborted.
All right, let's see if it's still on board though.
Let's try it again. Okay, it is talking.
Is this the right thing G?
Yeah. Okay.
Uh,
it'd be really cool when they have like plugins
where you can just click a button
that says I have a new API key.
And then you just post a doc URL
and it just does all this automatically, right?
I don't know if anything like that will ever exist.
Um, and remember, you know, uh,
right now if you have an API with perplexity,
you get all of 'em.
Uh, or if you have an account with perplexity, you get Chad,
GPT, Gemini Rock, all
of them for the same price.
Okay, so still typing.
And then, uh, g can you go ahead
and log into, uh, our support desk on
that VPS for me?
Yeah. Got it.
Building a tailored universal API ingest prompt
for control, global control.
Done saved key customizations of global control.
11 endpoints, fif, or 11 endpoint groups.
50 endpoints.
Uh, fire attack, fire, multiple tag trigger workflows,
broadcast emails, send need test first.
Safety, safety rules baked in verification.
Checkpoint must find exactly 50 endpoints across 11 groups.
Uh, run it.
Okay. Now the
good news is this is not as expensive as it is messing
with browsers and stuff like that.
So what I'm asking g to do right now
is make sure you're not showing
any personal information or anything.
G when we open that screen,
I'm gonna have him log into our support desk
and we're gonna turn on the browser control
and we're gonna ask Open Claw to go set up its own API key.
Make sense?
I know right now with a lot of the skills
that you can upload from like open claw hub
or whatever it is, uh, I was, um,
reading about it last night, a lot of 'em have been injected
with, uh,
malicious files, spyware, stuff like that.
So be careful when you guys find, uh, skills
that you can upload into your open claw.
A lot of 'em have irises right now, right? Okay.
So still typing.
Yeah, it's still running on the system.
How do you know it's still running?
Because I'm in the VPS.
Yeah. Okay. But looking at this screen, we can't tell.
It's running right on the phone.
I have Telegram on my phone
and I can see that it's still typing, right?
So, uh, does everybody know what to do with the API docs?
Now everybody, I'm gonna tell you right now,
open claw is gonna be 90% API
click cancel top right, and you'll see the typing.
Click cancel top right? Oh, look at that.
You were a genius, Chris. There we go.
I didn't know that was there. Oh man.
Some of the simplest things I tell you.
Um, but yeah,
open cloud will be 90% APIs in the future guys.
It will a hundred percent. It will. That's it.
This is how future, this is how software's gonna be ran.
Okay? So as soon as this is done,
this is what I plan on doing.
We'll go set up the fresh desk, we'll come back.
That'll be a brand new one.
We'll create a skill for Fresh Desk.
And uh, what I want to have happen is
I wanna create a, uh, skill for it every day
that will gimme a summary of the desk
and it'll tell me, uh, it'll,
it'll gimme a feel for what's happening.
Like, hey, there was, um, you know, a lot
of people asking about, uh, open claw, uh,
there was mastermind members that had this complaint.
Like, I can prioritize Mastermind, right?
Um, and so that'll help you guys start to understand
which API keys and how to integrate with the APIs,
but also understand that I'm okay
with it accessing the support desk,
but there's still things I will not let it access.
Okay? And it doesn't need
to do anything in there except report it.
Okay? So here we go. Pass to complete
50 endpoints found.
Hold on a second dog. 50 endpoint found.
Now extracting endpoint details on,
let's click off all these stupid things.
Uh, closing browser building skills,
now running verification tests.
Test passed Global control API
and just complete verify 50 endpoints.
Capture 11 groups, okay, files created
key discovery, endpoint summary, user one,
integration three, broadcast email four
contacts, five sub users.
Five tag seven custom fields. Five tag levels. Five.
Custom field groups. Five domains. Five tag groups. Five.
So it must have pulled up a user and found the endpoints.
I don't know. Or no, these are endpoints themselves.
All 50 endpoints documented
with the request response schemas.
Alright guys, that is a very thorough way
to train open claw on any API doc.
Okay. All right, G, go ahead and share your screen.
Okay, so do you want me to start from the A table
or where do we start from? Uh,
No, let's start from help desk real quick.
Let's start from fresh. Okay.
Okay, so we're logged in. Yeah.
Yeah. So I just logged in here
and I didn't want to, so the password, I could ask it
to log in, but I don't wanna do that.
And okay, it's already logged in here
And we give it browser control.
Yeah, we are gonna give the browser control
and then ask it to do the API.
Exactly. Just say go set up your own API key.
I opened up the browser for you
and we can sit here and watch it.
All sorts of things.
Big techie guy, you oh my gosh,
G is so much nicer than I am.
I'm just like, hey, I opened a tab for you.
You can access it. Go find my API key.
Can you zoom in where we can see it more? Yeah.
Okay. There you go. Hey, let's do something new.
Let's create a skill from scratch.
We have Freshdesk as our support desk.
We want a skill where you access this
API and do all sorts of things.
But to begin with, we need the API key and the API doc.
I have logged in a session
for freshdesk@nicelysupport.com login.
Can you do that? It should just be able
to see the existing tab, right?
Yeah. But just to make sure,
because face desk is a bit unique.
It has like bunch of login us,
so I don't wanna mess that up.
Okay.
Can you open that tab? Yeah.
So it just opened this one. It's go there.
Oh, it's trying to access the A PII guess.
Let's see what it does.
Yeah, so it again, trying to get the admin.
How come it just didn't go to the one
that you already have logged in?
That's what it does for me.
Let's see if it can figure something out.
It's opening the contact.
So gee, help me understand.
If you're already logged in, it's right there on the screen.
You can't just tell it to go to that tab.
Yeah, I think I can do that too.
Yeah, make it easy on people.
If you guys logged in,
it should just be able to go right to the tab.
As long as you've clicked that little thing on.
Set everything up for me.
Yeah, so it should be able to go on that tab and do that.
Can you click on your first tab
and make sure it's the active one?
I'll try again. Or if it's easy to steal me,
what exactly you are is
That, did that little thing turned on on that tab?
Yeah, but uh, let me actually open that up
and then so it that
Sometimes I have to turn it off
and back on for it to trigger.
You might try that.
I've never seen it do that for me.
It usually just takes over. There we go.
It took in now. Yeah,
It's trying to get the API like it's trying to navigate
to ur it didn't find it. Let's see what it does.
I think it's a matter of turning it off and back on guys.
It triggers something. I've done that before.
Oh, it opened up a new tab.
Okay. Edit agent.
Yeah, it's trying to go to the settings in find the API.
By the way, I've done this several times.
Uh, every single time I've done it, it's been able
to successfully do this guys.
But keep in mind this is also
where you're gonna spend the most money.
So I'm showing you that it can be done this way,
but if you can do it yourself
whenever you're doing with the browser, you really want to,
especially with something like setting up an
API key or something.
Yeah. So it's about to find the API
and it'll open up another tab.
So it's got three tabs open. Yeah.
Is it giving you a message?
Yes. What a way to find it. Click your profile.
Click profile setting. Scroll down,
you'll see your API key copy and paste it here.
Then I'll build the first skill for you.
Say you find it,
is it doing anything in those tabs?
She,
Uh, nothing yet.
The thing that I don't like about it,
I wish it would just give you an update.
I wish it would just say, hold on, I'm still working on it.
Like something
found view API key.
Okay, let's look.
Okay, it's saying I'm not a robot.
Let's see what it does for that.
Is it that tab or the one before?
This is the tab. We click that button
and it pops pop this up saying I'm not a
robot and it is a robot.
So there's a capture to confirm.
Let me check what's in that confirmation.
Maybe it'll confirm that it's not a robot.
Dude, if it can confirm it's not a robot,
that's not a good thing.
Yeah.
Okay. Go ahead and click it. That's a good thing guys
Thing. Yeah, it's a robot.
So we gotta do this part.
That's a good thing that it can't do that, right?
Also, we we're gonna have to change,
uh, API key after this.
It's gonna sew on the call. Yeah, that's our API key.
That's fine. Okay, let's see what it does now.
Okay, it's saying that, uh,
you should see it on your screen now.
Can you click the zig box to confirm?
Then I'll grab the API key.
So I just did that and this orange layout that is running,
that means it's still doing the work.
So it'll grab the API key. Now it's suit.
You don't have to tell it you did it.
No, it's just saying that.
So this orange window is something
it's currently running with.
And meanwhile let me start building skill.
So it's working on this skill.
So you come back and then check that pace again.
Has it always flashed like that?
Yeah. Am I going blind or what guys?
Did you guys know that that's how you can tell it's running?
I had no idea that thing flashed like that.
Yeah, it will always did that.
Okay, so your first is,
um, yeah, so it got the API key
and it actually closed the tab.
So I was looking for the tab. It's already
gone. It closed everything.
Okay, so did you guys see
that it grabbed the API key from the browser?
It set it all up. It created the API key.
It did all that stuff,
Right? Yeah. So
what I can do now,
so it already created this skill, right?
So it can list the list in source for ticket,
create the ticket, reply to the ticket, add private notes,
source, contacts, list, group and agents.
Okay, What do you want me to do?
I wanted to gimme a summary at nighttime.
Uh, how many open tickets we have, how many were resolved?
And an overall, how do I say this?
An overall,
I gotta use the word summary again, like an overall summary
of what the tickets were about.
So now you guys are seeing how we're using APIs that don't,
uh, belong to titanium.
Now we're, we're we, we've used, we've used one for Zoom,
we've used one for Vimeo
and now we're using one for Freshdesk.
Uh, did it not save it?
The memory got compacted because we are using the browser.
Yep. Did it, did it uh, did it save?
Its API key and everything though.
Yeah, there's a skill. Lemme check.
Yeah, first a skill right here.
All right, so let's see if it can
add that to my daily report.
You can check this first, right?
If it can actually get the open
ticket and then I can do that.
Well, we should do the same thing.
We should take the a PA docs, right?
And we should run it through and,
and train it properly on the skill, right?
Yeah.
Okay. So do, do they have API docs
And did not read that one though,
Huh?
Um, we already have this skill created
with API docs, right?
Not for Freshdesk.
We didn't find API docs for Freshdesk, right? Let see.
Fresh Desk. Lemme see if I can find them.
API docs just
'cause we have an API Key guys doesn't mean we
have the docs, right?
Fresh test developers here they are. View the API docs.
Okay, I'm gonna give you the link. Okay G
Um, it actually got the API docs
as well. When you are doing that
Well yeah, but we do it properly for everybody.
Let's, let's go into GPT. Let's create that prompt.
Let's do this properly. Yeah.
Okay. All right. I just put it in the chat.
Okay. Did you send me the doc?
I just, I just put it in the general chat.
I don't know where else to post right now.
It's developers dot Fresh Fist.
Yeah, there you go. This is it, right?
Yeah, that's the one.
So you guys can always go to Google
whenever you get an API key, go to Google,
find the software, whatever it is, the platform,
and look for API docs.
And now we'll go, we'll take G'S prompt. Let's open up chat.
GPT. We'll go ahead and give it the fresh desk, okay?
And then it's gonna give us big old thing
that we're gonna paste inside of Open Claw
and it's gonna create the best skill.
So there you go. He is gonna put the API doc there, okay?
He is gonna load that in cha GBT. There you go.
And now chat GP Z's going to give us this big old thing
that we're gonna go and drop inside of Open Claw.
See? So it's not only our software.
This is going to work for all software.
And then after this, we're gonna attempt to build
that bridge page again, guys
from the API, not from the browser.
And let me just check with you guys.
I know there's been a lot of repetition on the, uh,
API stuff, but it's really, really important.
Like I, I want you guys to sell on our software
and any software you connect, right?
Does ev does everybody get this?
Okay, so now he's gonna take this big old prompt
and he's gonna give this to Open Claw.
And Open Claw has no, no flexibility anymore.
It just needs to do exactly what it's commanded to do.
No guessing, no back and forth, nothing.
It's about as thorough as you can get.
See, it picks up really fast for you.
It's because you're doing it inside of the, uh,
the gateway dashboard. Is that why?
It's because you see this window.
This doesn't show up Telegram, because this is actual work.
Oh, you only get a message in the Telegram. That's why.
Got it. Because this is their system, right?
It can disappear and come back.
But on Telegram, you cannot do that.
So it doesn't give you telegram.
That makes sense. Okay.
Okay, James, good luck with your surgery.
That does not sound like fun.
If you're, you're onboarded though,
take your phone with you, man.
Uh, API version base, URL rate limits.
So it's probably been telling us this every single time,
every time we're doing one
of these API polls and we just don't see it.
Nice. All right.
So now that I have that, now
that I've tied into fresh desk guys, I just want you
to understand, this doesn't apply to most people on the call
because you don't have a support desk,
but it does apply for us
every single morning when I wake up, I wanna know
how much did we do in sales?
Uh, what was our ad revenue?
Uh, how many new newsletters do we have?
Uh, and then I wanna know
how many open tickets was there yesterday?
How many were resolved?
And was there any big concerning issues
in the support desk, right?
Those are things that I wanna know in addition to, uh,
and we'll talk about, uh,
probably tomorrow I'm gonna have you guys build a second
memory, right?
Um, there's gonna be reasons why we do that.
Uh, so that way when you have ideas
or something, you can just store it in your memory, right?
Um, so there's gonna be a lot if you guys will just continue
to talk to this thing and teach it skills
and help it understand your business, then the rest
of the time I'm gonna give you guys a series
of prompts I want you to load in there.
So it opti it optimizes your memory,
it optimizes your spend, right?
And it starts to take that role of the CEO
more proactive rather than reactive.
Does that make sense to you guys?
So spend some time with it, help it understand you.
And like I said, ask it. You know, what's your idea on this?
What do you think we should do on this instead
of you telling it what it should do?
Okay? Uh, let's see. It's still flashing.
Oh, I know why I didn't see it flashing.
'cause I was in telegram. It ain't gonna flash in telegram.
I'm also curious, gee, if you can ask it,
how much did it take?
How much did you spend to do this?
Uh, whatever this thing is here with this API,
Just this process.
Like giving the API,
Yeah.
Yeah. We can ask it
after this one once it completes this, right?
Because it takes like a minute to do this, right?
Yeah. But, uh, right now, uh, okay, it's creating skills,
going through the folders.
Yeah. Their doc is pretty thorough as well, right?
Like it's a big doc.
Even, even when we were doing the APIs
and all of that, it had a big doc.
So I think it's trying to get everything at this point.
So let me, um, Pade, are you on the call right now?
Yes. What were you specifically hired to do?
In my company?
Uh, sorry, What were you specifically
hired to do in our company?
The integration APIs?
Yes. What this thing is doing right now,
you have always had to do by hand.
Yeah. How much is this saving time for you?
Effort understanding? Is it making a difference for you?
Yeah, it's saving a lot of time.
Yeah. You don't have to figure things out anymore, right?
Right. Yeah.
We have a lot of, um, plans for how this is gonna integrate
with our software.
Two guys, with the integrations and the GC
and everything that we're doing,
we're already working on it.
It's gonna be really, really good.
We're not gonna use this manual process anymore.
Um, okay, so, uh, gee, while it's doing that,
let's open up the Airtable.
Let's clear it. This is what I would like to get done today.
I'm gonna give 'em a prompt so that they can start going to,
uh, uh, a more CEO rule so that they can be, uh,
more proactive than reactive.
Uh, I'm gonna give 'em that
and I want to see if we can build that bridge page today.
Can we do that? So
let's look at the Airtable first.
Okay. Um,
lemme see if I have it open right?
Yeah.
Okay. Do you see the, right
Now we have two problems. Yeah.
Yeah. So we didn't have anything on queue.
It's go to in progress.
Oh, I think that's completed as well.
There was one before and that's completed once.
And then in problems.
We still have to, we have reached out
to them from support desk.
Uh, let's see if they get back.
So Kathy Nielsen, are you on the call right now?
Kathy Nielsen. She is not. She was here yesterday.
And is it Ryan Johnson?
Sean Johnson. It says
Sean Johnson. He's
not on the call either. Okay.
So we'll keep reaching out on support desk.
So those are the only two problems we have.
And everybody else is onboarded, right?
Yeah. Every everyone else is already installed, so yeah.
Okay. Uh, is this thing still processing?
Okay. Is that the new stuff?
Yeah. So it's saying, I think it's completed
Fresh test, fresh Desk can complete past five.
Very fixed summary. So this is all coming from
that prompt we gave, right?
So pass one past two. Yeah.
So it's doing the past five
and then, yeah, all of this stuff.
Now let's use it to answer your quiz in
a question about open tickets.
I need your face desk credential.
What's your first desk domain? What's your face desk?
API key. Okay, so this is a bit unique one
to work the face, first desk, um,
API you need the first desk domain as well, right?
So ours is this one.
Like, it's, it would be different
for every single, uh, company, right?
So, uh, we have to do this
and then want me to save the credential to this one
and check those tickets.
Okay.
Got it. Let me check your open tickets now.
Okay. Uh,
so we have four open tickets right now.
Got it. Say, can you see anything marked urgent
or high priority?
Oh, it, it's already saying, so
all our status open and priority low.
So none of those ones are high.
Okay. Um,
okay, that's good. Yeah.
So I already closed.
Okay, so here's what I need GI don't need
to see a detail of the open tickets.
Just say, can you give me a summary of how many are open,
how many are pending, anything urgent?
And just summarize the day together
and then include that in my greeting every morning.
Every morning, Yeah. For the day before, right?
Yeah, The previous day.
Okay. So that's all I wanted guys.
I don't want it to respond to anybody.
I don't want it to do anything else.
I just want it to give me, uh, this warm fuzzy feeling.
Here's the other thing that we're gonna do right now. Uh,
so it's gonna show us a sample of
what this is gonna look like.
There we go.
Found your morning greeting.
Let me update it to include the Fresh Desk support summary.
Nice. That's gonna be so good.
All right. That's, that's what I like.
Your 8:30 AM summary will include add stats,
the support desk, total open tickets,
how many are high urgent priority tickets closed yesterday,
and then top three, uh, priority questions.
Okay, so support for open zero, high urgent,
three close yesterday.
Good. That's it, guys. That's it. That's all I wanted.
I just wanna know, I wanna know
overall, how do we do on sales?
How do we do on ads?
How do we do, uh, over here in our support?
You guys understanding this, this becomes super,
super valuable and think what you're gonna be able to do
for your clients in the near future, right?
I could also start getting into
how many subscribers did we bring in yesterday?
How many clicks did we get? Right?
There's, there's so many indications I can get every single
morning that tells me, uh, how my company's doing.
So, okay. Just type the chat here before we move on.
Does everybody understand that we just went
and had Open Claw connect our API
for us it found the API set it up, connect it,
it trained itself based off the prompt we gave you today.
And now we just went
and set up a, a very simple indicator, uh, from that API.
Pretty cool, right? And now it's set on autopilot.
It'll do that every single day for me until we decide,
uh, you know, later on.
There's some things I can do.
I suppose at any given point, I could say, um,
I don't know if there's like a trigger
or G where if something hits, like
that's urgent in the support desk, it,
it notifies me or something.
I don't know how that works yet.
I know we could do it on CR jobs
where you could go scan the support desk once a day
and let me know anytime it gets over 20
tickets or something like that, right?
Yeah. So when you set this up,
this is basically a Chron's up that does in the morning.
Yeah. So it can still do that,
but if you want something urgent, it's not possible
unless you do it like every hour or something,
Right? Right. You gotta
set up jobs. Okay. Yeah.
Can we continue with where we left off yesterday?
Um, yeah. So if you remember yesterday we went
and we were able to clone a bridge page.
We were able to, uh, it was able to go grab the Vimeo video.
It was able to transcribe it, and it went
and cloned the bridge page, and then it had to stop there.
So, uh, the reason why is
because it was missing a bunch of endpoints.
So we added the endpoints last night.
Now I think we should be able to get the replay,
look at the replay, download the transcript,
create copy from that, clone the bridge page,
open up the bridge page, paste all the copy,
paste the URL change, URL, change the name,
even change the SEO metadata settings,
and then set it up to do it every single
Monday, every single Friday.
Damn. If we can do that, all I could say is damn right.
I would've hired a staff member just to make sure
that got done every week.
All right, so how do we pick up on that G?
If you remember yesterday we told it.
We'll come back to this.
Yeah, so let's see the updates on the API doc itself?
Yep. And I already gave it to it. I
We already updated the dock itself. The skill?
Yes. Okay. I was test, I was testing it last night.
Okay.
I think you call it Vimeo Bridge page or something, right?
It wasn't membered.
Mm. Yeah,
It was something with Vimeo Bridge pages.
It was getting the newsletter replay,
you said we'll pick up on it later.
I don't know if it actually didn't saved it knowing
it's gonna pick up later.
We were building the local newsletter, replay workflow,
colonial Bridge pages for each week.
Back then we had to do it through the browser
because we didn't have the API,
but now we have the full Ling API.
Okay. I's gonna go check.
Okay? So it's a current newsletter.
Bridge pages 20 28, 27, and 26.
Next is 29.
Now I can do the whole workflow via API,
no browser needed the flow loan, the 28, name it,
29 have the URLS 29 new date,
new Vimeo, URL.
Want me to create the 29 now?
Just need the Vimeo URL for the week and then, okay.
I think it can, I think it could finish 28, right?
Um, it never
Finished. Did we not
did you not do it manually after that?
No. Okay.
I don't know. I mean, we can start over.
Whatever you think. I know you just named it manually.
That's all you did, but it didn't go on the
page and change anything.
I'll tell you what, here's what you should do.
Go into the bridge pages and delete that last one.
Just have it start over.
Have it create, okay, let's just do that.
That way we can see how fast this thing goes from
start to finish, guys.
Okay. And I think when you guys see this right here,
this is what excited me most about this is
how fast it could work through the API
because it's almost free.
You're almost gonna have a free VA from this
when you are doing all the browser work and everything.
Yeah, it's gonna look a little bit different, but um,
yeah.
So we can just delete number 28, right?
Perfect.
All right. Okay. How about this? Let's redo 28.
I deleted the current one, so you have to do it from 27.
Let's do it from the very beginning.
From grabbing the video L from Vimeo itself.
All right, so it's gonna go into Vimeo.
Uh, make sure your browser's closed too,
so it can't ever use the browser,
right? Can we turn that off?
I say API token has expired,
so it just went on Vimeo to grab new one.
Oh Yeah. So that's what it's doing right now.
How often does that happen?
I have no idea. We gotta check the Vimeo.
It's the Vimeo thing.
Okay, so it's just gonna go
refresh its own token.
Yeah, that's what it's trying to do.
I didn't know that VM UAPI would expire like that.
I guess they're just using tokenized.
Oh, okay. So it says it's not trying to get the API token.
It's trying to get the video.
Yeah, so turn out the browser so it can't do that.
Oh, it got it though. It got it,
but it didn't get it from the browser.
So can you just kill the browser
so it cannot possibly open it?
That's how you kill the browser guys.
Just shut that thing off
and then there's no way it can open up.
It'll tell you to click it, but you don't have to. Right,
But we still need the Vimeo key.
Should I give it the vier key?
Yeah, sure. Okay.
So what did it do? Grab the bridge pages.
Um, it hasn't done anything.
It has, it is trying to get the video from Vimeo, right?
Yeah. So yeah, let me get the key
and then give it gimme a minute.
Are we absolutely sure it's expired too?
And it's not just saying that
Yeah, it would expire.
It wouldn't say, uh, otherwise.
Like it tried to make the API call
and it probably gave that error saying API key expired.
While you're doing that real quick,
I'm gonna show him something else.
Okay? Uh,
go back up here guys.
We have two really good prompts for you today,
but let me go back to where I was earlier,
okay, this one.
Okay, we can do this one or,
Okay, yeah, there's this one.
This is the one. Okay, see this prompt here guys.
You are my operator. I run a business
and carry a heavy workload.
I need leverage, not just assistance.
Your mission is proactively remote work from my plate,
improve my systems, create meaningful progress without
waiting for constant instructions.
Core objective, reduce manual effort, improve workflows,
increase revenue opportunities, build systems.
I wanna wake up thinking open clog,
got real work done while I was sleeping.
Operating per principles. Be proactive.
If something could be approved, optimize automated, built.
Do the groundwork. Learn my environment,
understand the tools, platforms, workflows I use.
Look for automation opportunities, process improvements,
revenue optimization and content repurposing, cost savings,
time savings, better organization, uh,
bottle workflow bottlenecks, build safely,
create proposals or pull requests only.
Do not publish or deploy changes automatically.
Let me review and approve anything before it goes live.
Monitor where permitted.
Identify inefficiencies, missed opportunities
or performance drops and suggest improvements.
Nightly build mode every night. 11 o'clock.
Enter focus build mode.
Create or improve something meaningful.
Even small improvements, compound over time.
Daily report format.
Each session should produce what was created or improved.
Why it matters. Expected impact, time saved revenue,
potential efficiency gain.
What needs review or approval suggested. Next steps mindset.
You are not a chat bot, you are an operator.
Think like a systems engineer, a process optimizer,
a growth assistant, a reliable team member.
Your job is create leverage and reduce overwhelm
and steadily improve the business.
If you'd like, I can also make a short person note. Okay?
That right there is going to go from reactive
to proactive.
Is there anybody that would like to have this?
And what I suggest you do, time
to chat if you'd like to have this.
If not, that's okay.
What I suggest you do is you give this to chat GBT
and you say, here is my open claw on
autonomous operator directive.
Please make this work
for me and my company.
Okay? Lemme make sure I got it all.
Alright, here you go.
Uh, gee, where can I put this?
Do I just need to start putting this in Google
Docs or what should I do?
Yeah, those are some long prompts.
So I think Google Doc would be better.
Okay, hold on just a minute here guys.
So with with, with all the prompts that we give you,
remember what I proved to you is
that chat CCPT knows you better than your family does, okay?
So if that's the case, always run your prompts,
always run them through chat bt and ask it.
Say, how do I make this more customized for me?
Does that make sense? Alright,
let me see if I can open this up here.
So we'll create this doc file
and I'll call this, uh,
open claw shadow.
I don't know if they're prompts or what.
These are, are commands. They're commands, right?
They're commands.
Okay? So let me just do this share.
I'll get this to you guys right now.
We're gonna keep doing this, by the way.
I hope you guys are okay with that. Okay? So
let's say insert, uh, line, okay?
Uh, open claw shadow commands,
uh, with all of these,
all of these commands.
Ask chat GPT to make it
customized to your business first.
Okay? So here's that one,
and then I'll just remove
these lines so you don't get confused.
Okay? And then let me get the one that we did with G today,
okay?
And we'll keep giving this stuff to you guys.
If you find it valuable, you guys find it as valuable.
Uh, can you put the one that you did again in the chat, G
so I can just grab it easily?
Let's see.
Okay, let me, lemme get that for you.
Insert thought there was a
title, but I can't remember.
That's fine. Okay,
It's in the chat.
Okay, I'll make this stuff prettier later.
Oh, you know what? I can just get it off of chat.
GBT, right G?
Yeah, yeah, Let me do that. So it's the right format.
So that's gonna be down here.
And is it this? No, it's not this.
Uh, where is, where's yours? Is it this?
Yeah, just above that you'll see it.
The genetic one? Yeah, that one.
Okay. This. Okay,
I'll put explanations what this stuff is too, guys,
since I feel a little bit better.
But, um, why
the heck is it doing that now?
So this is gonna be 11 aerial 11, okay.
So we'll do this aerial 11 for you guys, Ariel.
Okay. Aerial 11 and then bold.
Okay,
There we go.
And this one's 17. Got it. I know what I did wrong.
Okay. 17.
Okay, so here's the two that we did today, okay?
And, uh, tomorrow I'm gonna give you another one, uh,
where it's gonna start optimizing your token spin,
because it's gonna round robin, your, not round robin,
but it's gonna select your AI model
for you depending on the tasks that you're doing, right?
We're gonna get into, uh, building better memories.
There's all kinds of cool stuff that,
that we're gonna start doing.
But just remember, guys, I'm gonna put this in the chat.
Let me know if you guys can see that.
Just remember that I want you
to start changing this up a little bit
and start saying, so what's your ideas for this?
Or what do you think we should do with this instead
of you trying to tell it what to do?
Because I think you're gonna be super,
super surprised at the super human, the super not human,
the super employee, uh,
that you have working for you right now.
Okay? Uh, okay. How are we looking on that thing g? Good?
Yeah, I can see it now.
Okay, go ahead and share while I clean this up.
We stop sharing. Okay. You should be good.
Okay. Yeah.
So the reason the token got expired was because it uses auth
and that's the token it was using
and it had to go back and do that again.
So, yeah, let me continue with the process. Did
They have to do that every time?
Um, if it's in oath, it expires.
Like if you don't have the refresh, it expires,
but now it's on this, so
you don't even have to worry about that.
It'll do it automatically.
Okay. All right. So now it's gotta go get the video. Yeah.
Yeah.
By the way, can you guys see that Doc?
It's uh, LNHG.
You're doing a hockey video.
Okay.
Okay. So it's flashing, so it's working.
Uh, I will tell you guys that
80% of our spend on our platform,
which I don't even think we've done 500 bucks, to be honest
with you guys, has been very unnecessary.
It has been learning, it has been trial and error.
It has been blowing stuff up,
it has been testing different things.
When you are just dealing with the API docs
and you do exactly like we showed you today,
your cost can be very, very minimal when it's just working
behind the scenes in the APIs.
When it's on Aron job, this is gonna be
so cost effective, it's not even funny.
All right? So 27 exists, but it's blank.
We just need to configure it.
Okay? So it, it knew that it has to be 27, right?
So it said 27 is blank and it was created on February 3rd.
So probably the February 2nd video should go there, right?
So it figured that out
and it's saying, okay, so the 27 is completed,
the replace there, let's actually check
Did it clone it? What did it do?
It just updated the 27th.
Okay, let me, lemme ask it to do the 28th.
Yeah, let's start over. 'cause I have
no idea what just happened.
Holy smokes guys. This thing is moving fast.
It already went and found the video,
it transcribed it, it looked at the content,
it created a sub headline.
A headline, a call to action.
It placed a video, it placed Vimeo, it pulled it.
Geez man, let's do that again. That was too damn fast.
Okay, so it's cloning 27 to 28. Okay.
Did it already pull the video?
Yeah, it already pulled the video
because it, once it has the token,
it doesn't even have to like it.
It told me that, um,
February 10th was last Monday call, right?
But we canceled it and it just told me, uh, I looked for
February 10th, there's nothing there.
Maybe the video was not uploaded
just saying me all of that stuff.
And I was told that February 20 10th was canceled.
So we only have February 2nd, right?
So now it's saying, okay, 28 is created. This is the link.
It's actually open it here. Yeah, there you go.
The video is there. The title is there.
Did it name it? Did it name it do Dude,
it is going way faster than I thought it would.
Let's see if it actually created and named it.
Like guys, this is going super super fast.
Yep. 28 news tower. That's the latest one, one view.
That's probably me on the open cloud.
What did it do? It hasn't done anything
with the copy yet though.
It's still got the old copy.
So now it's gotta go in the page
and do all the magic in there, right?
Yeah. Lemme see. Uh,
but I didn't see new user driver video.
The must sent is February 2nd.
Yeah, just ask. Did you just ask it to use that one?
No, it already did it. Just saying that.
Okay. Oh, okay. Yeah, you're right.
So it's on 27th,
but for the new one, I don't have the new video.
It's what it's saying.
Guys, you're seeing it work with two APIs right now
at the same time.
Uh, like a single prompt. Did you guys see that?
It went and grabbed that video?
Transcribed that video, figured out
what the copy needs to be.
Clone the bridge page. Renamed the bridge
page, changed the path.
It couldn't find the video for, uh,
it assumes a video from the second,
the clone copies content, which has February 2nd.
Copy. Let me set. Okay,
is that all new one?
Could you update the date or first copy for,
Is that all original copy?
Yeah, so you just reading that from the copy, it's,
it's kind of confused with
what we're doing right now from our instruction.
And the confusion is the 27 had the same video
and this is the same video, right?
And it's just saying you are putting the same video.
Why are you doing that? Are you yet
to bring the replay or something like that?
So let's do this g you ready for this? Yeah, let me see.
27 again.
Okay, See our replays are really low
right now 'cause we're not mailing out.
There's seven clicks. Delete 27, delete 28, delete both.
Let's have it create this for reals. Can we do that?
Yeah, Yeah. Delete 27. It'll be okay.
I don't think anybody's gonna click on it right now.
So now this is going to be a real life scenario guys. Okay.
And what it would do is we end that call at about 1130.
And so my plan is at two o'clock Aron job kicks in,
goes into Vimeo, grabs that replay,
downloads the transcript, transcribes it, figures out
what the copy needs to be, goes into pop links,
create clones, the last replay names it change the URL
opens it up, switches out the copy,
switches out the video URL
and then writes the email,
updates the webinar description with the new replay.
I just cannot believe how fast that was.
So once it learns this process,
we're just gonna put it on Aron job and forget about it
and you guys will never not have a replay again.
And tomorrow we didn't get the end points done last night.
Tomorrow we're gonna have it take that replay
and put it inside a course Sprout
listing is 26 so it knew, it knew the last one was 26
now cloning 26, setting up 27.
That's good.
And it got the video as well. February 2nd.
It grabbed the video from February 2nd.
Dude, this is crazy.
It's absolutely insane man.
Okay, while it's doing that,
let's rephrase maybe the pace already
it's there, it renamed it as well.
Maybe it's working on it. Let's see.
Yeah, so live URL is that, that's the video
and that's your headline.
That's your CTA. So everything is brand
new. Yep.
Is it original copy or did it copy the last one?
I have no idea. Let me look at what it said again.
'cause I know how we're gonna automate your whole entire
article and newsletter.
Build out. You won't do a thing.
Ask it, say I want you to change the copy.
Make sure it's a hundred percent original with a new hook.
Oh my god, it's
so much easier than I thought it was gonna be.
Guys,
is there anybody surprised on how fast that went?
Just say just, okay. Just choose the best.
I can't stand options. Just choose the best.
We should tell it. Chad does not like options.
Just always choose your best.
That was one thing that drove me crazy about Chad GPT when
it started giving you all those options, right?
Like a confused mind doesn't do anything.
Okay, let's see what the page looks like now. Yep.
We just cracked the code on a hundred percent hand entry
news and it's insane.
And this is your software line.
The, uh, let's see if it can do it.
I don't know if we can or not ask it.
If it can put the highlights in the, uh, in the text section
or the copy text.
The, the text block or whatever it is.
It's in the end point. I just don't know what it's called.
So I don't know if we want to call it timestamp highlights
or what we want to call it, but can it do it?
Um, you mean something like this?
Let's say this is highlighted.
Is that what you're saying? No,
No. Down below the video
there's a section you can turn on
where you can put all the bullet points and everything.
Remember PNE used to do it by hand?
Yeah. What's that session called?
It's a text block. Yeah.
Have it inject all the highlights,
have it make a nice format
and inject the highlights under that video.
You guys aren't saying much.
Are you guys not blown away with what you just saw?
I am absolutely shocked at what I just saw.
My god, if I was a va I'd be scared half to death right now.
Okay. So since I highlight, uh, asked for the highlight,
it went back to the back to the video
and saying let me get the transcript
for the every second call.
Yeah. So it it, it is trained.
Uh, Josh we told, we gave it the API to Vimeo
and we said go get the video and just drown.
Just download the transcript
and then transcribed the transcript.
So yeah, this is a skill in our system right now.
Yeah. So any uh, any um, you know, video platform
that you have, make sure they have an API
make sure they have an API, right?
Um, it's crazy
because now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna say, okay, uh,
the last part of this process is write the follow up email
and send me a test.
Okay, let's see what it did with the page.
Did it not update that?
I don't see it? Well it said added highlights
pulled from the transcript.
You'll probably have to tell it what the endpoint is, right?
Or something. I I think it has a certain name.
Now we'll have to, you have to really give us things,
some thoughts or you'll have
to really give us stuff some thought, right?
Because we'll have to go back and tell it.
You are not allowed, never ever should you delete a video
or anything without my permission, right?
There's some rules you guys probably gotta think about when
you give it access to stuff.
Lemme see if I can find the name on the endpoint.
GI just don't think we're referring to the right name.
Lemme see, This
is what's crazy to me.
I would, I was looking to hire,
'cause I gotta do the same thing in this company.
I was looking to hire a VA just to make sure
that replays got out.
'cause this number one complaint we have in our support desk
is replays don't get out on time.
Everybody wants our replays, right?
Guys, I don't even think as fast as that thing just did
that, I think that would've cost me less than a penny.
Is that not insane?
Oh, you see that said, Yeah,
So the, it actually created the
text block but it was hidden.
So the API doesn't expose rotation settings di directly.
That X block is saved but hidden in base layout,
you try using bullet instead.
Okay, so how do we, This is standard
feature, so it's doing something. Let's see.
So we can probably just go turn it on and see what it
Yeah, but let's see if it can find a workaround for that.
Okay, I've done safe text block content with highlights.
Save six bullet points with highlights problem.
Both is text block enabled
and bullet is enabled, say stays at zero
and the setting keeps this module as false.
The P doesn't expose this toggle.
So yeah, it added the bullet point is
what it's saying, but it's hidden.
So let's see.
Yeah, so click on those squares on the right side.
Uh, it says it's on.
Yeah, so this is what it added the bullets.
Yeah. Okay. So even if it's on, yeah, this is what it needs
to fix or maybe we need an A
API endpoint for this one too, right?
So you see it already added those.
So can it also make sure the formatting is nice?
Yeah. So this is how it looks like
and I turned it on.
Okay. Yeah, this is,
we're just training this thing right now as we go, right?
Yep. Okay.
Holy crap.
Yeah, Seriously
It did that.
Ask it to make it clean on white.
Okay. It doesn't look as
as good on white. So
Just say, all we wanna do is, I I was impressed
with that ability though.
Just say all we wanna do is have really nice notes
and can you also timestamp it to the video?
Really nice notes, format it nice
with a timestamp if possible.
Oh, you know what it can do?
Gee, I'll bet it can hyperlink it.
To jump to that point in the video,
we need to train it on how to create the Vimeo URL
to jump to that timestamp.
Right? Unless it knows how
Right. It's annoyed.
I'm telling y'all this is the future. Do you guys see it?
Nothing has excited me with AI
until I knew this was out there.
This is the future and it's just gonna get so much better.
Okay? It's trying to get the timestamp.
Once we get this perfect,
we're gonna tell it there's your skill.
Do it every Monday. Do it every Friday. Who knows?
I might do some more calls now
that I know I have these abilities out there.
Uh, it'll probably be able to train itself Josh.
That's a pretty standard thing.
Okay, let's try and click this. Okay.
It timestamp to that and it went to three minutes.
Wow. So
we just have to work on the format.
Let me see what it's, what
it's actually creating on the page.
Okay. Introduction to Pacino,
how Open Cloud Monitors local Summerland stores it live.
Demo AI creating article Letterman for Okay,
ask it say make it more personalized to Chad
and this audience.
Say he's very personal with his audience and make it fun.
And let me do something else.
Now, obviously this is probably a good, a good,
a good example guys where we could get the perfect
layout and everything with Chad GPT.
He could probably take a screenshot
of this right now and say,
This is exactly what I'm doing.
Yeah. This is what I want open Claw to do.
So gimme the prompt where it's gonna understand it. Okay.
And that way we're not going back
and forth inside of open claw.
Uh, you want me to do the prompt or just train it?
Uh, we'll put pa paste that in Chad.
GPT Ask Chad GPT how to, how to give a command to open claw.
That's gonna give us a slay.
So you're an open claw right now, right?
Can we go to Chad GPT? Yeah. Paste that in there.
Say can you gimme a command?
So it's gonna do this kind of formatting?
I think, I think that's a developer thing Josh.
I think we can have it to where when they click on that,
it'll just forward to that place in the video.
Right? Gee, it doesn't have to take 'em to Vimeo, right?
Um, no I think it would be,
you cannot have both
of those two parts embedded at the same point.
Like what I'm saying is this is a base.
You have a link that is connected over there. Yeah. Right.
This is a link. You cannot manipulate this.
Okay. Then it might not not,
we probably don't want have it hyper LinkedIn.
We probably just wanna have the timestamp.
Okay. But I know when I built
ever lesson we had it
where it would jump to the point in the video.
Yeah. We can explore that. Maybe give something like that.
Okay.
Yeah. Just say I want have the bullet point
for like this for open clock.
Can you give me the command?
Hold on. Don't give it that. Hold on.
Just do the output format rules.
You don't need that whole thing
that that's gonna screw it up.
G go back to it. Chat. GPT went above and beyond for that.
That's not what we want. So look, output format, rules.
Let me look at that first line, then a list of bullets.
Each bullet must do this. Do not, do not, do not.
And then everything below that doesn't matter.
You just need that output format rolls up above.
You can use example down
there too if you want.
Right? Um,
and then I would just add when you, when you give it
to Open Claw, just say make sure you make it personal.
He's very personalized with
his audience or something like that.
Make it personalized and fun.
Not so, um, formal maybe is the word.
Gee has so much more patience than I do man.
I am so short with this thing.
It's pretty crazy to me though that it's making changes
inside the software right now.
We've been waiting a long time to see that.
And I imagine it can create a lead step and a bridge page
and everything from scratch too.
Okay. We have the video now
and yeah, there's a timestamp.
It did it for the full length as well. Yeah.
Yeah. It's getting there. It definitely has some,
it definitely has some formatting issues.
Yeah. I wonder, here's what I wonder if we go on the page
and we make the formatting issue, right?
Can it just go look at the page?
Say, okay, I could do it like that.
Yeah. And that's what we should do.
We should not let it keep trying to do it.
We'll just go finish the page ourselves,
get the perfect format and then
it'll do it every single time. Yeah.
Yeah. And uh, to begin with
that we shouldn't have done this either.
We could have just given it the emails
Could have what We could have just given it the emails
and that would've been easier.
Yeah. Well we learned everything the hard way. Right?
Okay. I'm gonna do a test right now. You ready for this?
Yeah. Talking to it. Yeah.
It can create a lead step, right?
Uh, don't do it yet. Did you already do it?
No. Okay,
because we are talking, uh,
we are training this right now with this skill.
Right? And you're gonna say something else.
It's gonna forget the whole thing we did in this call
and then you won't have it.
Okay. Can you tell we'll pick up.
'cause I don't wanna sit here and format this
thing with these guys on the call.
Okay. So we'll just pick up later, right?
Do you guys understand what we're doing?
We're just trying to get it trained on that whole process
and then we're gonna tell it to memorize the whole thing
and set it on Aron job and we're done and we're done.
And we'll just let that thing go every Monday, every Friday,
whatever other calls we have,
every webinar we do, whatever we do.
The, the is are you guys
starting to understand this right now?
Let's see. I got one person that said yes.
Chris says yes. Chris says yes. Okay, good. Alright.
Now here's what I'm gonna do.
We're gonna do the ultimate test right now.
As soon as G tells me I'm clear, somebody tell me,
look, I'm gonna tell you guys right now, I'm make a lot
of money with lead steps and bridge pages,
especially when somebody just clicks a link
and it takes 'em right to the confirmation page.
My God, have we got that figured out?
But somebody tell me what we can create a, uh,
a bridge page on what can we do?
Or let's do a lead step. What can we do on the lead step?
Hold on just a minute while I check on
this poor doggy out there.
Are they still talking to you?
Yeah, it's still going through it.
Is it just saving everything?
Yeah. That's what he's trying to do.
And we definitely confused it.
We should've just went in the page,
guys set up the formatting exactly how we wanted it,
and just said, go look at the formatting.
That's what we want.
Updates, kills everything we learned. OAuth credentials.
If token fails, working token, full workflow transcript,
download process, complete nine step bridge page,
replay workflow, all update endpoints,
documented text block, bullet limitations, meeting notes,
format added notes about using au.
Dang, man. Okay, we're ready?
Yep. You can continue now.
All right, let's try it. Let's just try this real quick
guys, then we'll wrap up the call.
I didn't mean to keep you guys so late, but let's try this.
Let's try this.
Hey, can you create a lead step for me?
Okay. I sent in an audio typing.
I'm gonna be very, very vague. Okay.
What do you wanna call it? Uh, what do you wanna call it?
What's it for? Uh, okay,
one second.
Sorry, I don't have a lot of time, so I kind
of need you to figure this out.
Uh, but I just want
to have a really good hook on why people should be
using open clock.
Can you just create the whole entire page for me? All right.
I did not give it any information, guys.
Now what I can do is I can train it so that if I ever do
that stuff, this thing is trained
to make controversial hooks.
Follow marketing formulas.
You know, the, the, uh, marketers love language,
like all that stuff, right?
But let's just see, I'm just curious to see what it does
with very, very limited information.
So what it asks for, it says, can you give me the name?
What's it capturing leads for?
So I can set up the headline copy
or if you have a specific one to clone
or modify, let me know which one would you guys agree.
I gave it nothing. Nothing.
I just said it was about open clock.
And let's see how it does with zero training.
It's learned on the tech side.
It hasn't learned on the marketing side yet.
Okay, so it's still typing.
Okay, I'm gonna just say I'm not even read it g I'm just
gonna say, just go with it.
Obviously I could give it some feedback.
Uh, is it reflected on that screen?
Oh, it already created it. Sorry. It already created it.
It was giving me a recap. Can look at, yep. Lead page.
What if you had an employee who worked 24 7, never asked
for a raise, and Ashley got smarter every day?
Headline about the 24 7 employee gets smarter.
Sub-headline about an AI that takes action.
Six compelling bullets.
CTA focus you may need to toggle bullets on.
All right, let's go look at it.
That's the pace.
Okay, hold on.
So now what I can do
is I can start training it on what makes a high converting
lead capture page.
And basically if I tell it, uh,
uh, hold on a second, refresh it.
I'm surprised it turned on the bullet though.
Turn off bullets
refresh.
Okay, hold on a minute. Try again.
I'm just telling it. Do a different, different template.
Yeah. It's reflecting here now since
the template and it's doing that. Yeah.
I see How fast it is.
You see how fast what's gonna happen, guys?
I don't ever wanna lose pop links in, in, uh, the lead steps
and bridge pages 'cause it's, it's the core of my business
that nobody else understands.
Okay? But what we're gonna do is we're gonna start bringing
AI into creating the layouts, the templates, the backgrounds
and everything, right? Okay. So now
It did this one. Now turn
Off those bullets.
It cannot turn off. The word said. It's saying that
It can turn off the bullets.
Okay? So we had to do something in the AI in the API
where they, it can turn stuff on and off, right?
Yeah. Okay. So we'll do that tonight. All right.
Refresh it again.
This is the latest one. No, I told it to do it again.
Uh, this now? Yeah,
No, it did this.
And then you said turn off the bullets.
It's saying I can do it with API.
Okay. Okay.
And it's telling you to turn it off yourself.
It takes five seconds. Okay, now it's on template 12.
I rephrase. Yeah, this is what it did.
Can you go tell it to turn out the bullets
Again?
No, you go turn it off. Sorry.
You go turn out those bullets.
Okay. We'll have an API guys working can toggle stuff
on and off, you know,
but right now we didn't even think of that.
Uh,
refresh that We could tell it
to always refresh the thumbnail too, right?
I think we could do that from,
I know we can do the SEO meta settings from it.
Um,
you're in a bridge page, right?
Or in lead step. Where did they create it?
It's a, it's a lead step, right?
Yeah, I was looking for that.
Oh, um, yeah, employee. Is this the one?
Yeah, this is the one, yeah.
Oh, I just had to rephrase. Okay.
Yeah, just go in there and then turn out those bullets.
Um, Yeah. Click the background.
Yeah, turn off the bullets.
It is off. Turn off the text block.
Okay. And then turn on the bullets. This one,
I don't want bullets either. Just turn
that off. You don't want none of
that stuff on lead capture pages.
Okay. Now, uh, what is the top two things up there?
Okay, let's do this.
There is some text.
Discover the, okay, make that white.
Yeah, make it bigger real quick.
You know, I gotta ask it something you need to ask it.
Did it change colors? Because if it's
choosing templates, it should not.
We gotta tell it not to change colors or anything
because there's no way that should be broke.
Yeah, that's not how you do that.
Something's wrong with that. Okay.
So I don't know what it did.
I don't know what block that
is 'cause it's got yellow stuff.
So let's start again. Let's delete this one. Hold on.
I'm gonna tell something new. Gimme just a second.
Ire learning here guys.
Hey, I need you to create a new lead capture page
or a new lead step.
Um, and this one's going to be
about Claude versus Chad, GBT
and how Claude Outsmarts
and outperforms, uh, Chad GBT.
Do not change any colors.
All right, let's see what happens. And
that was a half-assed instruction too, right?
So let's see what it does.
I'm gonna tell it no bullets, No text.
It's funny because I hear everybody saying that.
Um, I saw a very, very big marketer the other day saying
that lead capture pages were dead.
He was never gonna use 'em again to, uh,
you gotta hop on this webinar
to discover the new technology everybody's using.
And when you click the link
to set up on the webinar, guess what it was?
Only capture page. It's, they're never gonna be dead.
They're never gonna be dead ever, ever. Okay?
Uh, all right. There's a new page, G,
why smart entrepreneurs are ditching chat, GPT for Claude
and never looking back.
Okay, go into your pop links.
Okay? It said it took five seconds in the editor.
Oh no, it's telling me to toggle stuff off.
Yeah.
Okay, so today just turn it off.
No, I don't understand.
Why do you keep adding
a text section?
I don't want that on at all.
Yeah, go ahead and turn it off.
Got it. No text box noted for future. Hold on a minute.
I'm gonna change a template now
because you can clearly see everything on that page.
But let's start changing the template.
Let's make sure that it doesn't change colors again.
Template seven. Alright, go ahead.
It's doing something in the top part G,
It's adding this block or something.
No, there should be a three part headline there,
but it's adding something up there.
I don't know what it's doing, Right?
So we have to figure that out.
But other than that, I'm
convinced this thing works pretty well.
So what I plan on doing guys, is go into, uh, real quick,
uh, g go into the lead steps.
We're gonna try one more test.
One more test to prove my theory here if I'm right or wrong.
All right, do me a favor.
Go down to,
um, go down to that one.
Uh, go down, down, down, down, down.
Go down to one of those LCPs down there. Uh, right there.
Go go to that one, the offerman one.
Open that up real quick. Let me see that.
Okay, scroll down. This is one
of the highest converting pages we have.
Okay, so here's what I'm gonna do.
Give it that URLG say, take a look at this format.
If you have to go into the
software, whatever you need to do.
When I tell you to create a
lead step, I want it to look like this.
So can you go look at the elements
and figure out what you gotta do by default?
I want it to look like this.
I think that's where we're screwing up guys.
I think we're better off creating what we ideally want,
letting it go look at it, figure out whatever it needs to,
and then see if it can create it.
And we keep finding that out over
and over and over the hard way.
Do you guys see that?
It must be studying every element in that page, huh?
Yeah. See, it's able to see it
as a customer guys.
It can click the link and look at what the customer sees.
It can also go in the back end from the API
and look at the font size.
Look at everything, right?
It can look at the line heights
and we can be even more specified with it.
Okay? No video disabled, no text block, disabled headline.
Look at that. Look at that, man. Look at the default.
It's gonna start with. Now.
Now also the reason I could have also said, just
whenever I tell you create lead step,
just go clone this page
or go clone the one that has the most views.
I could have done that too, but the way
that pop links works is you always have a unique
look, right?
Um, so headline, good.
Sub headline, CTA bullets video off text block off.
Okay, so let's try it. I'm gonna try it again. You ready?
Um, uh, what, what,
what should we write a page on this time, G We'll do, um,
Yeah, you can do that.
Can you create a lead step on the local newsletter?
Just come up with a really, really good hook for me.
And by the way, didn't learn that though.
It's, it reviewed that,
but it save that to memory what we just saw.
Yeah. Yeah. It should be journaling everything.
All right, this is the final, final chat guys,
and then I'll let you guys go.
Uh, did I lose it?
By the way, when that happens and you're not sure it saved
it to memory guys, just go copy what was up above
and say, here, save it.
There's been plenty of times where he told me his loss,
his memory or whatever, and I just go
and copy what was above and give it to it again, right?
Let me add a killer hook. Here's what I'm thinking.
Attention local business owners and side hustlers.
How smart people are building five to 10 KA month.
Many media empires in their own backyard
while everyone fights the algorithm.
Discover the local newsletter strategy
that's creating new income streams in towns just like yours.
Let me set this up. Whatever. FTC nightmare there.
I ain't gonna run that, but I like, I like, uh,
the training you, Scott.
All right.
Did it give it a URL? Want me to update the two pages?
Yeah, sure. Ask it to do both pages.
I I was worried that we hadn't done the thank you page yet.
Is there anybody seeing the potential with this at all? I
got one more super cool thing to show you guys
as soon as this gets done.
We'll see how it does with this.
Um, but I'm gonna tell you right now, lead steps
and bridge pages are probably one
of the biggest revenue generators in my business.
Seriously, I don't care what comes out.
You automate lead steps and bridge pages for me. Oh geez.
I mean, I can't tell you guys how many times I've been on a
call and I need to stop
and set up a lead step if I gave something away or whatever.
I did it the other day on a webinar with Tim Re
now I can just send an audio message.
Hey, go set up this lead step real quick.
Oh, let's ask it to fire off a tag too.
All right, that's it. There's your URL,
it even chose a URL.
Do you see that?
It did the meta too.
Okay, let's actually see it.
Dude, are you, we can't under,
we cannot keep up with what it's doing.
Do you see how it's like thinking for itself?
Let's see if it actually created something.
This should be the base. Oh,
it selected titanium call.
It was the mistake.
Yeah, that domain's not up right now
though. We took that one down.
Oh, okay. Yeah,
So just set it to a general one real quick.
I just wanna see what it did. Yeah,
yeah, just do a system domain
that's, or you can do that one.
It's getting better. Try to often.
So it has to learn the formatting, right?
Like it didn't follow the formatting.
Yeah, But
change the template.
Do not adjust a thing. Lemme see what happens.
Okay, so it has the,
Yeah, that's just default though.
It didn't change anything there. Oh
Yeah.
Alright. That's okay. We can work on that.
But let me go back to it real quick. Uh, watch this.
See how, um, there's zero tags there.
Well refresh the template real quick.
G let's see if it changed. Just
go back to the front end and refresh it.
Hold on a second. Hey, can you make sure that
that tag also fires off?
Chad test
You take this template.
Okay. See, so if it just follows, I'll work on that.
We'll get that thing perfect, right?
But I think I can also,
I, I think I know what to do with that.
I think I could just take that one bridge page, clone it,
save it as master template, and then just say,
whenever I ask you to create a lead step,
just clone the master template, rename it, change URL,
put the new hook in there.
Yeah,
Yeah, Because it's very, very easy
to say change the template, right?
Yeah. Alright, let's see.
Did it, did it change the tag?
Did you say something? Did it?
Yeah, I just sent an audio message. Hold on.
I'm still typing. Okay,
Got got the chat taste tag.
Oh, let me attach. Are you guys working?
Are you seeing this? I just told it.
Hey, don't forget the tag. And I told it. Which tag?
So now go refresh your, your
just go refresh your dashboard, see if the tag's added.
No, I don't see it.
Okay, that's what I needed to know.
So we don't have the ability
to sign the tag to the page yet.
I'll add that endpoint tonight. But watch this guys.
This is where I am so excited. You ready for this?
Um, watch this.
Hey, uh, John Danel, D-A-N-E-L-S,
John danel@gmail.com.
Fire off the tag test.
Chad,
you guys see what I just did?
When you guys understand the power
of our tags, I'm at an event.
I just met somebody, I just sent an audio message.
Okay, watch what this thing's going to do.
You ready for this? Watch this.
Still typing. Still typing.
Contact created. Now let me apply the Chad test tag.
Hold on a second. It says for me it's done over here.
G, can you refresh?
Yeah, it did. So up now? Yeah, there you go.
Look at that guys. Do you see what just happened?
Do you understand what can happen when that happens?
That person could have just put into a series of workflows,
had multiple integrations fired off,
dropped into a sales pipeline.
Look, look at everything we just did from a simple
audio message.
Can you go open up GC real quick
and show 'em that that tag just,
that contact just got created.
And then I'll show you guys one more thing.
This stuff is exciting guys. I'm sorry.
But that is super, super exciting
when you're sitting there talking to somebody at an event
and you do what I just did.
Hey, do me a favor, firefighter.
And they're sitting there and then all
of a sudden they get a text, they get an email, like,
come on guys, all that happens.
You just got access to my membership.
You just got this free gift.
I don't think they understood what just happened.
So go to gc, please.
All right, let's go look and see what just happened.
Open claw just created a contact.
Where is it at? Is this the right account?
It is John Daniels.
J-O-H-N-D-A-N-E-L-S.
Chad Test. Uh,
but I don't see it.
Did it just make me eat my words?
johnDaniels@gmail.com created
and tagged with Chad Test.
Oh, did it do that in gc?
Yeah, it didn't do that in GC
Because it could have done it in course Brow, right?
We tested that a lot and we saw it work.
Two 12. There it is, right there, guys. Look at that.
Look at that. You see that?
I fired off that tag from the audio message.
That's insane to me.
Watch this.
Hey, can you go into gc?
I want you to pull up the contact record for, uh, garb.
G-U-A-R-A-V.
Let's just see, let's see what it's got on you, G.
So I asked it to go into global control
and I asked it to just find G by name.
That's it, that's all I asked it.
Okay, let's see what it returns.
Well, here's the thing, Robert.
He says, you better be careful
that you don't actually tell it.
Delete data before you ever delete data.
I want a confirmation first.
I want you to get permission from me first, right?
You guys gotta think of these things
and you gotta start putting precautions in place.
All right, so I got it on my screen.
It says I found 116 contacts with Garv.
Here are the main ones.
Um, what is your main one that you use?
GT I 40
at Gmail.
Is it gonna refresh on your screen? Let's see.
So I'm gonna give you main
Email.
I'm gonna give you your main email
and let's see what it pulls up.
Oh, I spelled it wrong. G-A-U-R-A-V
dot s
u@gmail.com.
Okay, here we go. What's it say?
Yeah, it's catching up.
That's what it does when the channel sends it.
Oh my God. Give it, give it a second.
But I saw a glimpse like it showed when
it was active, all of that.
It gave a list. Yeah. There you go.
Yeah, scroll up. Look at this here guys.
So you want details on one of your contacts?
Can you scroll up?
Uh, I'm trying to,
Maybe it'll look. It's
still trying to update. Yeah, now it's there.
So look, I said this is the email I want.
There's a phone number, there's a country.
The day is created. Last active email is valid,
status is active.
Here's his 28 tags.
Do you guys see this?
We can then go and,
and somehow it knew that that was the one that I wanted.
I guess we can then go and tell it.
Okay, tell me how many workflows this person has.
How many emails have they opened?
We can do anything with these endpoints.
Are you guys seeing this right now? It's absolutely insane.
The information that you have at your
fingertips right here in Telegram.
This would allow one person
to track multiple clients in four different businesses.
Yeah, we're just playing, man.
We only, all we did was play with our APIs for one day.
That's it for one day.
So you guys have this for Letterman, you have it
for course route, you have it for Global Control,
you have it for pop links and you have it for Mint Bird.
And now you know how to you start using it for platforms
that we don't own, like Freshdesk, Vimeo,
zoom, right?
Let me just ask you guys, before I conclude with you,
are you guys getting a lot of value outta this?
On a scale of one to 10, you
guys getting a lot of value outta this?
Is this workshop helping you see what we saw
and the reason why we went in fully on board
and we're like, we know this is the future.
We know this is what our software's been waiting for.
It's good. And remember, once you get it all trained
and the exercise we did today
with the API docs is gonna really help you.
It's gonna minimize your cost.
Running this stuff like it is now does not have
to be on a high price model
and it is not gonna cost anything even when
it is on a high price model.
So ask it, gee, how much did you spend just now to do that?
Uh, how much it spin?
What did it cost me to pull up that contact record?
Yeah, but what about the API cost?
Did it say 5 cents? There's no way. I think so.
There was no, there's no way that was 5 cents
that one poll. There's no way.
I think it was 0.05 or something. Let's see. Oh, okay.
0.05.
Okay. I was like, no way. Alright. So there you go guys.
You just gotta, man, you just gotta get this thing trained.
You gotta get it to know the APIs,
follow the lead we gave you today.
When it's running normally, this is not gonna cost anything.
It will not cost anything. All right.
I have kept you guys long enough.
Does everybody have the, uh,
you can stop sharing your screen G.
Does everybody have the, um, the Google doc
that we created today on tomorrow's call?
I'll give you some more prompts.
We'll keep adding to the doc.
Uh, I'll give you some more prompts.
Um, and then we're going to play with Course Sprout.
We're gonna take the replay.
We're gonna drop the replay into Course Sprout.
Uh, can somebody give Josh the Google Doc?
We'll put the replay into Course Sprout.
And then I'm also gonna take a video.
I'm gonna put it in Dropbox. Guys.
I think one of two things.
I think, number one, I can go drop a series of videos
for a course in Dropbox or Vimeo.
And I think this damn thing can go build the whole entire
course for me.
Meaning look at the video, transcribe the video,
create the short lesson, create the loan description,
create the goal block,
figure out what the points need to be.
Generate the badges, right?
The goal blocks for every single video.
I think it could do everything for us. Everything.
I'm 99% sure aren't you g?
It's just a matter of an understanding. That's it.
So we're gonna dive into that tomorrow.
Uh, and then the day
after, I think we're gonna conclude with the big kahuna,
which is where we'll take a video, we'll cut it up
with opus clips or something like that,
and we'll see if we can syndicate it out to, to Networks.
Yeah. Good stuff, right guys? Is it good?
All right. Well, I'm gonna go get to work with my team.
If you are a mastermind member today,
we're not gonna do a call today.
Uh, it just, this is just taking too much from me right now.
It's just taking my voice away.
Uh, but, but, uh, I hope you guys are excited. This is good.
It's gonna get really, really good.
Alright, thanks everybody.
I will, uh, get the replay in there, uh,
and you'll be off to the races.
Keep us posted. All right. Bye everybody.